Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In the late 2000s, life was going well for 27-year-old Annie Hindutcher. The engineering graduate had a good job in Stockholm at the headquarters of multinational telecommunications company Ericsson and had recently purchased her own apartment with some help from her parents.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用或我们网站上本期节目的简介。在 2000 年代末，27 岁的安妮·欣杜彻（Annie Hindutcher）生活过得非常顺心。这位工程学毕业生在斯德哥尔摩跨国电信公司爱立信总部找到了一份不错的工作，并且在父母的一些资助下，最近刚买了自己的公寓。
Annie's close-knit Hindu family were of Indian heritage and had immigrated to the southern Swedish town of Marriastod before she was born. Although Annie had moved away, she returned to her family home often, maintaining a close relationship with her father, mother, older sister and younger brother. In 2009, Annie's aunt, who was the family's expert matchmaker, introduced her to a young man named Shreyan Dawani. 29-year-old Shreyan was two years older than Annie and was from the English city of Bristol. Like Annie, he had Hindu parents and was one of three children with an older brother and
安妮关系紧密的印度教家庭拥有印度血统，在她出生前就移民到了瑞典南部城镇玛丽亚斯塔德。尽管安妮已经搬出去住，但她经常回家看望家人，与父亲、母亲、姐姐和弟弟保持着亲密的联系。2009 年，安妮的阿姨——家族里经验丰富的媒人——将她介绍给了一位名叫什雷扬·达瓦尼（Shreyan Dawani）的年轻男子。29 岁的什雷扬比安妮大两岁，来自英格兰城市布里斯托尔。和安妮一样，他的父母也是印度教徒，他是家中三个孩子之一，上面有一个哥哥、
a younger sister. Shreyan had an economics degree from Manchester University and worked for his family's successful business running nursing homes throughout England's west country. Although Annie and Shreyan lived in different countries, they soon struck up a long-distance friendship. During a visit to London, Annie went on her first date with Shreyan. They attended a West End performance of The Lion King before having dinner at an upmarket fusion restaurant.
下面有一个妹妹。什雷扬拥有曼彻斯特大学的经济学学位，并在家族成功经营的企业工作，该企业在英格兰西部乡村经营着多家养老院。尽管安妮和什雷扬生活在不同的国家，但他们很快就发展出了一段异地友谊。在一次伦敦之行中，安妮与什雷扬进行了他们的第一次约会。他们去西区观看了音乐剧《狮子王》，随后在一家高档融合餐厅共进晚餐。
The couple had a wonderful time, with Shreyan particularly liking the way Annie made him laugh. Despite the long distance, their relationship blossomed over time. In February 2010, Annie decided to relocate to the United Kingdom, a move that would help develop her connection with Shreyan. Her father Vinod and mother Nalaam gave her their blessing. Annie quit her job at Ericsson, and on March 1, she moved in with her cousin in Luton, a large town about 50km northwest of London.
两人度过了美好的时光，什雷扬尤其喜欢安妮逗他笑的方式。尽管相隔异地，他们的感情还是随着时间推移而不断升温。2010 年 2 月，安妮决定移居英国，这一举动将有助于进一步发展她与什雷扬的关系。她的父亲维诺德（Vinod）和母亲纳拉姆（Nalaam）给予了她祝福。安妮辞去了爱立信的工作，并于 3 月 1 日搬到了伦敦西北约 50 公里的大镇卢顿，与她的表亲同住。
Shortly after the move, Annie called her parents to announce that things were going well with her and Shreyan, and that she had been welcomed by his family. Several weeks later, Vinod and Nalaam travelled to the UK to meet Shreyan's parents. It was a whirlwind visit that included afternoon tea, a tour of Bristol, and dinner at an Indian restaurant. By the end of the evening, everyone agreed that the meeting had gone well. On June 10, Shreyan took Annie to Paris on a private jet. After gifting Annie a design address and Christian Dior shoes, Shreyan took her out for dinner
搬家后不久，安妮打电话给父母，宣布她和什雷扬一切都好，并且受到了他家人的热情欢迎。几周后，维诺德和纳拉姆前往英国拜访什雷扬的父母。这是一次紧凑而愉快的访问，包括下午茶、布里斯托尔观光以及在一家印度餐厅共进晚餐。傍晚结束时，大家一致认为这次会面非常顺利。6 月 10 日，什雷扬用私人飞机带安妮去了巴黎。在送给安妮一件名牌裙装和克里斯汀·迪奥（Christian Dior）鞋子后，什雷扬带她出去吃晚餐。
at the Ritz Hotel. Instead of dessert, Annie was presented with a diamond engagement ring worth £25,000. The couple began planning their wedding. They initially wanted to get married in Dubai, but after an impromptu visit to India, they fell in love with Mumbai and decided to have the wedding there instead. Annie and Shreyan planned to have four traditional Hindu ceremonies, but because these wouldn't be legally binding, they would make the marriage official at a UK registry office after their honeymoon.
地点是丽兹酒店。没有上甜点，而是送上了安妮一枚价值 2.5 万英镑的钻戒。两人开始筹备婚礼。他们最初想在迪拜结婚，但在一次即兴访问印度后，他们爱上了孟买，决定把婚礼改在那里举行。安妮和什雷扬计划举行四个传统的印度教仪式，但由于这些仪式不具法律效力，他们打算在度蜜月回来后，在英国的婚姻登记处正式注册结婚。
On Thursday October 28, 2010, the wedding festivities began at Mumbai's Renaissance Hotel. The lavish celebrations lasted for three days, costing the Hindocha and Diwani families around £200,000 altogether. The wedding concluded on Saturday October 30, with a reception held by the Diwani's. Those captured the newlyweds beaming, with Annie dressed in a blue and green saree, and Shreyan wearing a silver outfit with a scarf that complimented his bride's clothing. After the reception, the couple farewelled their loved ones, with Annie and her family weeping as they said their goodbyes.
2010 年 10 月 28 日星期四，婚礼庆典在孟买文艺复兴酒店拉开帷幕。这场奢华的庆典持续了三天，欣杜查家族和迪瓦尼家族总共花费了大约 20 万英镑。婚礼于 10 月 30 日星期六落下帷幕，迪瓦尼家族举办了一场招待会。照片定格了新婚夫妇灿烂的笑容，安妮身穿蓝绿相间的纱丽，什雷扬则穿着银色西装，搭配一条与新娘服装相呼应的围巾。招待会结束后，两人向亲人们告别，安妮和家人在道别时泪流满面。
Shreyan had intended for their honeymoon destination to be a surprise, but before he could tell Annie where they were going, his mother let it slip, that he had booked a trip to South Africa. Annie and Shreyan arrived in South Africa on Tuesday November 9, 2010, and immediately travelled to the Chitwad Chitwad Game Lodge, a luxury five-star resort located inside Kruger National Park. The couple spent three days visiting the park's feigned sites and animals. On Friday November 12, Annie and Shreyan caught a flight from Johannesburg to Cape Town, where
什雷扬本想将蜜月目的地作为一个惊喜，但在他告诉安妮之前，他的母亲说漏了嘴，透露他预订了去南非的旅行。安妮和什雷扬于 2010 年 11 月 9 日星期日抵达南非，并立即前往位于克鲁格国家公园内的五星级豪华度假村——奇特瓦德野生动物度假村（Chitwad Chitwad Game Lodge）。两人花了两天时间参观公园内著名的景点和动物。11 月 12 日星期五，安妮和什雷扬搭乘航班从约翰内斯堡飞往开普敦，
they would spend the remainder of their holiday. Cape Town is the second largest city in South Africa, located on a peninsula in the country's southwestern corner. Today, it's known for its busy harbour, white sand beaches, and the imposing table mountain that looms nearby. Capetowns can ride cable cars to the top of the mountain, or travel a short distance to visit the world-famous wineries just outside of the city. Despite Cape Town's natural beauty and popularity with wealthy travellers, it has a complicated
他们将在那里度过假期的剩余时间。开普敦是南非第二大城市，位于该国西南角的半岛上。如今，它以其繁忙的港口、白色的沙滩以及附近巍峨耸立的桌山而闻名。游客可以乘缆车登上山顶，或者短途旅行去参观城外世界著名的酒庄。尽管开普敦拥有自然美感且备受富裕游客青睐，但它却有着复杂
history and is also home to significant poverty and inequality. As a result of the Group Areas Act of 1950, non-white citizens of South Africa were prohibited from living in the municipal limits of any of the country's cities. All people of colour in Cape Town were forced out of the city's established neighbourhoods on the slopes of Table Mountain and into the Cape Flats, a sandy, barren stretch of land on the city's outskirts, where they established their own makeshift townships. Some managed to build themselves brick bungalows on the tiny plots, but most residents who lived below the poverty line were forced to live in densely packed squatter camps that
的历史，同时也存在严重的贫困和不平等现象。由于 1950 年的《集团区域法》（Group Areas Act），南非的非白人群体被禁止在该国任何城市的市政管辖范围内居住。开普敦的所有有色人种都被强行赶出了位于桌山山坡上的城市成熟街区，赶到了开普敦平原（Cape Flats）——那是城市边缘一片沙质贫瘠的土地，他们在那里建立了自己的简易城镇。一些人设法在极小的地块上建起了砖砌平房，但大多数生活在贫困线以下的居民被迫居住在拥挤不堪的棚户区里，
lacked electricity, running water, or sewage systems. Over the years, the Cape Flats population grew beyond that inside Cape Town's municipal city limits, and the area gained notoriety for being the dumping ground of the apartheid. When the South African apartheid ended in the early 1990s, residents of the Cape Flats were no longer restricted by segregation laws, but many remained bound to the area by language, history, economics, and ethnic politics. Cape Town's international airport is located in the middle of the Cape Flats. Visitors to the city travel along the N2 Highway, which passes by the sprawling shanty township
那里没有电力、自来水或排污系统。多年来，开普敦平原的人口增长超过了开普敦市区界限以内的人口，该地区因沦为种族隔离制度的倾倒场而臭名昭著。当南非种族隔离制度在 1990 年代初期结束时，开普敦平原的居民不再受隔离法律的限制，但许多人仍然因语言、历史、经济和族群政治而被束缚在该地区。开普敦的国际机场位于开普敦平原的正中央。到访该市的游客沿着 N2 高速公路行驶，途径绵延的棚户区，
to reach Cape Town's wealthy centre. Upon arriving at Cape Town Airport, Annie and Shreyaan exited the arrivals hall to look for a taxi to take them to their accommodation, the Cape Grace Hotel. Shreyaan found a friendly young taxi driver named Zola Tongo, who worked full-time as a limousine driver for a local tour company, but used his own vehicle to shuttle passengers in his spare time. Tongo loaded the newlyweds and to their luggage into his grey Volkswagen Charan minivan and drove them the 20-minute journey to their hotel.
才能抵达开普敦富裕的中心地带。抵达开普敦机场后，安妮和什雷扬走出了到达大厅，寻找一辆出租车带他们去下榻的开普格雷斯酒店（Cape Grace Hotel）。什雷扬找到了一名友善的年轻出租车司机，名叫佐拉·通戈（Zola Tongo）。他是一家当地旅游公司的全职豪华轿车司机，但在业余时间用自己的车接送乘客。通戈把这对新婚夫妇和他们的行李装进他的灰色大众夏朗（Volkswagen Charan）面包车里，开车载他们开启了前往酒店的 20 分钟行程。
There, he gave them his phone number in case they wanted to use his services again. After checking in, Shreyaan and Annie had a drink at the hotel bar, followed by dinner at a fancy restaurant located a short walk away. The next day, they spent most of their time relaxing by the hotel pool, before getting ready for dinner at 96 Winery Road, an upmarket restaurant located in the Helderberg Valley Wine Region, about 50 kilometres east of Cape Town. Shreyaan called taxi driver Zola Tongo, whom the couple had liked, to arrange for him to take them to dinner.
在那里，他把自己的电话号码留给了他们，以防他们再次需要他的服务。登记入住后，什雷扬和安妮在酒店酒吧喝了一杯，随后步行不远去一家高档餐厅吃晚餐。第二天，他们大部分时间都在酒店泳池旁放松身心，然后准备前往 96 号酒庄路（96 Winery Road）吃晚餐。这是一家位于开普敦以东约 50 公里赫尔德贝格谷葡萄酒产区（Helderberg Valley Wine Region）的高档餐厅。什雷扬打电话给这对夫妇很喜欢的出租车司机佐拉·通戈，安排他开车送他们去吃晚餐。
Annie dressed up for the occasion, wearing a black dress, a shawl, and black and silver high heels. She carried her blackberry phone in a small purse and wore a Giorgio Armani wristwatch, a white gold and diamond bracelet, and her diamond engagement ring. Shreyaan dressed in a dark suit with a white shirt. Tongo collected the couple and took them on a brief tour of the city at night, before heading on to the Yentu Highway towards the 96 Winery Road restaurant. As they drove, Annie and Shreyaan decided they didn't feel like eating a large, lavish
安妮为这个场合精心打扮了一番，身穿黑色连衣裙、披肩，脚踩黑银相间的高跟鞋。她把黑莓手机放在一个小钱包里，手腕上戴着一块乔治·阿玛尼（Giorgio Armani）手表、一条白金钻石手链以及她的结婚钻戒。什雷扬则身穿深色西装，内搭白衬衫。通戈接上这对夫妇，带他们在夜色中简单游览了这座城市，然后驶上恩图高速公路（Yentu Highway），朝着 96 号酒庄路餐厅驶去。车行途中，安妮和什雷扬觉得此时并不想吃丰盛大餐，
meal, so Tongo suggested they try the Surfside Restaurant, an Asian-inspired eatery in the nearby beach resort town of Strand. The couple agreed, and Tongo dropped them there at 9.30pm. Annie and Shreyaan dined on curry and sushi, with Shreyaan calling Tongo half an hour later to request a pick-up in 20 minutes. By 10.15pm, the couple were back in Tongo's minivan, returning to Cape Town along the Yentu Highway. Approximately one hour later, at 11.12pm, a 33-year-old government employee named Simbo
于是通戈建议他们去尝尝海滨餐厅（Surfside Restaurant），这是一家位于附近海滨度假小镇斯特兰德（Strand）的亚洲风味餐馆。两人欣然同意，通戈于晚上 9 点 30 分将他们送到那里。安妮和什雷扬享用了咖喱和寿司，半小时后，什雷扬打电话给通戈，要求 20 分钟后来接他们。到晚上 10 点 15 分，两人已经回到了通戈的面包车里，沿着恩图高速公路返回开普敦。大约一个小时后，即晚上 11 点 12 分，一名 33 岁的政府雇员名叫辛博·
Nile Madagazi was returning to his home near the Cape Flats township of Kailicha. Simbo Nile had driven a friend to the airport and was pulling into his garage when he noticed a stranger dressed neatly in a dark suit, standing on his doorstep. As visitors to the area were rare, Simbo Nile was baffled by the man's presence. The stranger approached Simbo Nile and said, Excuse me, is there a nearby police station where I can report a hijack, because my wife and I were hijacked? The man identified himself as Shreyaan Dawani, and Simbo Nile placed a call to the police
尼尔·马达加齐（Simbo Nile Madagazi）正返回他位于开普敦平原凯利恰（Kailicha）镇附近的家中。辛博·尼尔刚开车送完一位朋友去机场，正把车开进车库时，他注意到一个身穿深色西装、衣着整洁的陌生人正站在他家门廊上。由于该地区的访客极为罕见，辛博·尼尔对这个男人的出现感到十分困惑。陌生人走近辛博·尼尔并说道：“打扰一下，附近有没有警察局我可以去报案说遭遇了劫车，因为我和我妻子被劫持了？”这名男子自称是什雷扬·达瓦尼，辛博·尼尔随即代为报警。
on his behalf. As Simbo Nile spoke to the dispatcher, he asked Shreyaan for further information, such as the location of the vehicle and its make and model. Shreyaan was unable to provide any answers. He paced back and forth outside Simbo Nile's garage, crying softly until the police arrived 15 minutes later. Shreyaan regained his composure and explained that his wife had suggested taking a detour through the Cape Flats, as the area around their hotel felt too similar to her home in
在与调度员通话时，辛博·尼尔向什雷扬询问了更多信息，例如车辆的位置以及车辆的品牌和型号。什雷扬却无法提供任何答案。他在辛博·尼尔的车库外来回踱步，轻声哭泣，直到 15 分钟后警察赶到。什雷扬重新镇定下来，解释说他的妻子提议绕道穿过开普敦平原，因为他们酒店周围的区域感觉太像她在瑞典的家了，
Sweden and she wanted to see, quote, the real Africa. The tourism industry offered visitors official township tours through Guguletu, the largest of the Cape Flats townships. Accompanied by a guide, tourists would meet locals, see historical sites, and eat at a barbecue shack named Mazzoli's, which was made famous in 2009 when celebrity chef Jamie Oliver dined there and described the food as heaven. Tours of Guguletu only operated during the day, as the area was plagued by violent crimes at night, including rapes, assaults, carjackings, home invasions, and murders, which occurred
她想看看所谓的“真实的非洲”。旅游业为游客提供前往古古勒图（Guguletu）的正规城镇之旅，古古勒图是开普敦平原最大的城镇。在导游的陪同下，游客可以与当地人见面、参观历史遗迹，并在一家名为马佐利（Mazzoli's）的烧烤小屋用餐。该店在 2009 年因名厨杰米·奥利弗（Jamie Oliver）在那里用餐并形容那里的食物为“人间美味”而名声大噪。古古勒图的观光游仅在白天运营，因为该地区夜间暴力犯罪猖獗，包括强奸、袭击、劫车、入室抢劫和谋杀，这些罪案大约每两天半发生一次。
approximately every two and a half days. Despite this, the daytime tours were considered safe, as no major crimes had ever been committed against tourists. Although the area was known to be dangerous after dark, Annie and Shreyaan's taxi driver had agreed to take them on a late night tour of Guguletu. According to Shreyaan, as they were passing the international airport, Tongos minivan exited the N2 highway, first turning left, and then turning right onto Clipfontein Road, one of the main thoroughfares through the Guguletu township.
尽管如此，日间旅行仍被认为是安全的，因为从未发生过针对游客的重大犯罪。尽管众所周知该地区天黑后很危险，但安妮和什雷扬的出租车司机还是同意带他们进行一次古古勒图的深夜游。据什雷扬所说，当他们经过国际机场时，通戈的面包车驶离了 N2 高速公路，先是左转，然后右转驶入克利普方坦路（Clipfontein Road），这是穿过古古勒图城镇的主要干道之一。
They then drove past the Guguletu cemetery before making a few turns to drive past Mazzoli's, the barbecue restaurant made famous by Jamie Oliver. At that point, it was almost 11pm, and the streets were quiet. Then, just as Tongo was about to turn right back onto Clipfontein Road, a man leapt out and violently banged a handgun against the minivan windscreen. Another man suddenly opened the driver's door and forced Tongo out of the vehicle and into the back, where the couple were sitting. The man then jumped behind the wheel, while the carjacker with the gun took the front
接着，他们驶过古古勒图公墓，随后拐了几个弯，驶过了因杰米·奥利弗而闻名的烧烤餐厅马佐利。当时，时间已近晚上 11 点，街上静悄悄的。就在通戈准备右转重新驶回克利普方坦路时，一名男子突然跳了出来，用手枪狠狠地砸向面包车的挡风玻璃。另一名男子突然打开司机车门，将通戈强行拉出车外，推到了后座上——安妮和什雷扬正坐在那里。随后，这名男子跳上驾驶座，而持枪的劫车者则坐到了副驾驶座上。
passenger seat. As they sped off down the road, Annie began to scream and cry. Shreyaan attempted to shield her with his body, but the gun-wielding carjacker pressed the weapon against Shreyaan's temple and stole his watch, which was valued at £2,000. The gun also handed over between 5,000 and 6,000 South African rand in cash, or the equivalent of $4,500 Australian dollars. Annie was forced to hand over her Giorgio Armani watch and white gold diamond bracelet. After handing over their valuables, Shreyaan begged the carjackers to let him and his wife
汽车加速狂飙下路，安妮开始放声尖叫和哭泣。什雷扬试图用身体保护她，但持枪劫车者将武器顶在什雷扬的太阳穴上，抢走了他价值 2000 英镑的手表。这把枪还交出了 5000 到 6000 南非兰特的现金，折合约 4500 澳元。安妮被迫交出了她的乔治·阿玛尼手表和白金钻石手链。交出贵重物品后，什雷扬恳求劫车者放他和妻子
go. A distraught Annie spoke in the Indian language of Gujarati to let him know that she had hidden her engagement and wedding rings. Shreyaan attempted to hide his mobile phone in his trousers so he could later call for help, but one of the carjackers noticed and confiscated the device. The carjacker then held his gun to Shreyaan's temple and stated, Lie to me again, and I will kill you both. The driver continued north for several minutes before pulling over to the side of the road
一条生路。心烦意乱的安妮用印度古吉拉特语（Gujarati）低声告诉他，她把订婚戒指和结婚戒指藏了起来。什雷扬试图将手机藏在裤子里以便稍后呼救，但其中一名劫车者注意到了并没收了设备。劫车者随后将枪抵在什雷扬的太阳穴上说道：“再对我说谎，我就把你们两个都杀掉。”司机向北行驶了几分钟，然后将车停在路边，
and forcing Tongo out of the van. With the newlyweds still inside, the driver then continued down the street at high speed, smashing over speed bumps and swerving erratically. After faster he drove, the louder Annie screamed. The carjackers took Annie and Shreyaan back on to the N2 highway and headed away from Cape Town, deeper into the Cape Flats. After about seven minutes, they exited the highway at Barton Powell Drive and headed into the Kailisha township.
将通戈强行赶下了面包车。在新婚夫妇仍在车内的情況下，司机随后以极高的速度沿街道继续狂飙，碾过减速带并诡异地蛇形行驶。车开得越快，安妮的尖叫声就越大。劫车者带着安妮和什雷扬重新上了 N2 高速公路，驶离开普敦，向开普敦平原更深处开去。大约七分钟后，他们在巴顿·鲍威尔大道（Barton Powell Drive）驶离高速公路，开进凯利恰（Kailisha）城镇。
The armed carjacker continued to press his weapon against Shreyaan's head, but assured him they had no intention of harming the couple and only wanted the minivan. Shreyaan clung to Annie and repeatedly begged to be released. Approximately 20 minutes after the carjackers had thrown Tongo out of the van, Shreyaan was forced at gunpoint to climb out the back passenger window of the moving vehicle, leaving his wife behind. He found himself nearly 20 kilometers from where Tongo had been ejected. Shreyaan stumbled along for about 300 meters until he came to an intersection.
持枪劫车者继续将武器顶在什雷扬的头部，但向他保证他们无意伤害这对夫妇，只是想要这辆面包车。什雷扬紧紧抱住安妮，反复哀求对方放他们走。在劫车者将通戈赶下车大约 20 分钟后，什雷扬在枪口逼迫下被迫从行驶中车辆的后车窗爬了出去，把妻子留在了车内。他发现自己距离通戈被扔下的地方将近 20 公里。什雷扬跌跌撞撞地走了大约 300 米，直到来到一个十字路口。
The streets were quiet, so he knocked on doors looking for help, which is when he encountered Symbolnile Matacazi. Shreyaan was driven back to the Cape Grace Hotel by the police while a search was initiated for the minivan. At the hotel, Shreyaan phoned his family in the UK to inform them what had happened and that Annie was still missing. Soon after, another police car arrived at the hotel carrying Tongo. The carjackers had left the taxi driver approximately one kilometer from the Gugoletu police station
街道上一片寂静，于是他敲门寻求帮助，也就是在这个时候，他遇到了辛博尼尔·马塔卡齐（Symbolnile Matacazi）。警察用警车将什雷扬送回开普格雷斯酒店，同时展开了对面包车的搜寻。在酒店里，什雷扬打电话给他在英国的家人，告知他们发生了什么事以及安妮仍然下落不明。不久之后，另一辆警车搭载着通戈抵达了酒店。劫车者把这位出租车司机扔在距离古古勒图警察局大约一公里的地方，
and he had made his way there on foot to report the carjacking. Tongo told police he couldn't remember the names of his passengers but knew they were staying at the Cape Grace Hotel, so the officers had driven him there in a bid to find out more information. Shortly after midnight on Sunday, November 14, Shreyaan's father, Prakash Dawani, called the Hindocha household in Sweden to inform them what had happened. Annie's father, Vanod, asked for more information but Prakash said he knew nothing else and would call back when he did.
他步行到了那里报案称遭遇劫车。通戈告诉警察，他记不清乘客的名字，但知道他们住在开普格雷斯酒店，于是警官们开车把他送到那里，试图了解更多信息。11 月 14 日星期日午夜刚过，什雷扬的父亲普拉卡什·达瓦尼（Prakash Dawani）打电话给瑞典的欣杜查家中，告知他们发生了什么。安妮的父亲维诺德要求了解更多信息，但普拉卡什说他一概不知，等知道后再回电。
Through tears, Annie's mother, Nalaam, told her husband, Annie is never coming back. Vanod immediately began making plans to travel to Cape Town. He was looking into flights when Shreyaan called, sobbing as he told his father-in-law, sorry dad, I could not take care of your daughter. This was followed by another call from Shreyaan's father, telling Vanod he had found flights leaving from Amsterdam to Cape Town later that morning. Both men planned to fly to Amsterdam and then board the flight to Cape Town together. At 6am, Vanod boarded a two-hour flight to Amsterdam from the Swedish city of Gothenburg.
安妮的母亲纳拉姆泪流满面地对丈夫说：“安妮再也不会回来了。”维诺德立即开始计划前往开普敦。他正在查询航班时，什雷扬打来电话，泣不成声地对岳父说：“对不起，爸爸，我没能照顾好您的女儿。”随后，什雷扬的父亲打来另一个电话，告诉维诺德他已经找到了当天稍晚从阿姆斯特丹飞往开普敦的航班。两人计划一起飞往阿姆斯特丹，然后搭乘飞往开普敦的航班。早上 6 点，维诺德从瑞典城市哥德堡登上了飞往阿姆斯特丹的两小时航班。
This was incredibly difficult for him as he was out of contact with his family for the entire duration. When Vinod finally landed in Amsterdam, he found a payphone and called his brother Ashok. He heard crying and wailing, followed by Ashok stating, they shot Annie. Earlier that morning in Cape Town, the police had received a call from a resident of the Lita Park Township, not far from where Shreyaan had been forced to exit the minivan. The resident had noticed a grey, Volkswagen minivan parked adjacent to an empty, weed-covered field.
这对他的内心极其煎熬，因为在整个航程中他都与家人失联。当维诺德终于在阿姆斯特丹降落时，他找到一部公用电话，打给了他的兄弟阿肖克（Ashok）。他听到电话那头传来哭泣和哀号，接着阿肖克说道：“他们开枪打死了安妮。”当天早上早些时候，开普敦警方接到了一名利塔公园镇（Lita Park Township）居民的电话，该地点距离什雷扬被迫离开面包车的地方不远。这名居民注意到一辆灰色的大众面包车停在一片长满杂草的空地旁。
The vehicle was an unusual sight in the area and curious neighbors had peered through the windows and noticed there was a body inside. At 8am, police had arrived at the scene and immediately noticed that blood had seeped out of the rear right-hand door of the minivan and was pulling on the asphalt below. They opened the door and found Annie Hindoch's body sprawled on her back across the bloodstained back seat with what appeared to be a bullet wound in her neck. A bullet was lodged in the back of the rear right seat and gunpowder residue was found in various parts of the minivan.
这辆车在该地区显得很不寻常，好奇的邻居们透过车窗向里张望，发现里面有一具尸体。早上 8 点，警察赶到现场，一眼就注意到鲜血从面包车的右后门渗出，在下方的柏油路上汇集成一滩。他们打开车门，发现安妮·欣杜彻的尸体仰面横陈在血迹斑斑的后座上，她的颈部似乎有一个枪伤。一颗子弹卡在右后座的靠背里，面包车的各个部位都发现了火药残留物。
Beneath Annie's body, officers found her wedding and engagement rings stuffed into the small gap between the seats. Annie had been killed by a single gunshot fired at close range, between 5 and 10cm away. The bullet had entered Annie's neck and had grazed her hand along the way, indicating she had been in a defensive position at the time of her death. Although there were no signs of sexual assault, marks from someone's right hand were found on her lower left leg. A pathologist report concluded that Annie's death had occurred in a matter of heartbeats.
在安妮的尸体下方，警官们发现了被塞进座椅之间小缝隙里的结婚戒指和订婚戒指。安妮是被近距离发射的一发子弹杀害的，距离在 5 到 10 厘米之间。子弹击中安妮的颈部，并在途中擦伤了她的手，这表明她在临死前曾做出防御姿势。尽管没有性侵迹象，但在她的左小腿上发现了某人的右手印。法医报告得出结论，安妮在心跳间隙便已死亡。
A 21-year-old student who lived less than 100 metres from the spot where Annie's body was discovered, later came forward to contradict the findings that Annie hadn't been sexually assaulted. She said she had gone to look at the minivan when the police arrived and had been standing just 5 metres away when officers opened the vehicle door. The student claimed that Annie's head was by the door and her knees were bent up with both legs apart. Her dress appeared to have been pulled up around her waist and her underwear had been
一名住在距离发现安妮尸体地点不到 100 米处的一名 21 岁学生随后站出来，反驳了安妮没有遭到性侵的调查结果。她说，警察到达时她去看过那辆面包车，当警官打开车门时，她就站在仅仅 5 米远的地方。这名学生声称，安妮的头部靠近车门，双膝弯曲，双腿分开。她的裙子似乎被拉到了腰部周围，内裤也被
dragged down below her knees. The student told the Telegraph newspaper, quote, It looked to me very strongly that they had done something to her. I couldn't say if they raped her, but she had definitely been attacked. That I am sure about. Cape Town police denied that Annie had been found in such a state. The crime was described by Cape Town's mayor as a blow to all Cape Tonians and South Africans, while tourism officials urged visitors to be vigilant and only travel with tour guides.
拽到了膝盖以下。这名学生告诉《电讯报》：“在我看来，非常明显，他们对她做了什么。我不能说他们是否强奸了她，但她绝对遭到过袭击。这一点我很确信。”开普敦警方否认安妮被发现时处于这种状态。这起犯罪被开普敦市长形容为对所有开普敦人和南非人的一记打击，而旅游官员则敦促游客保持警惕，出行务必由导游陪同。
Local taxi drivers queried why Zola Tongo had taken his passengers to such a dangerous part of the city so late at night, with one telling the media, It is a dangerous place at night and every driver would know. Did he get lost? As if he was, it was the wrong place to be. Annie's father, Vinod, and father-in-law, Prakash, arrived in Cape Town at 9pm on the day her body was found, with Vinod having cried throughout the entire 12-hour flight from Amsterdam.
当地出租车司机纷纷质疑，为什么佐拉·通戈会在深夜把乘客带到城市里如此危险的地方。其中一人对媒体说：“那里夜里很危险，每个司机都知道。他迷路了吗？如果是的话，那可真去错了地方。”安妮的父亲维诺德和公公普拉卡什在发现安妮尸体的当天晚上 9 点抵达开普敦，维诺德在从阿姆斯特丹出发的整整 12 小时航程中一直在哭泣。
They were met at the airport by officials from the Swedish and British consulate, who drove them to the Cape Grace Hotel, where Shreyan was waiting. In a book Vinod later authored titled Annie Diwani, a father's story, he said he was struck by Shreyan's strength and how he was able to hold himself together when Vinod himself couldn't stop crying. The following afternoon of Monday, November 15, the police took Vinod to see Annie. They thought it looked as though she was sleeping peacefully and might wake up at any moment. Vinod kissed his daughter's forehead, told her that he loved her, and stated,
瑞典和英国领事馆的官员在机场迎接了他们，并用车将他们送到开普格雷斯酒店，什雷扬正在那里等待。在维诺德后来撰写名为《安妮·迪瓦尼：一个父亲的故事》（Annie Diwani, a father's story）的书籍中，他提到自己对什雷扬的坚强印象深刻，在维诺德自己悲痛欲绝、泪流不止的时候，什雷扬却能保持镇定。第二天下午（11 月 15 日星期一），警察带着维诺德去见安妮。他们觉得看起来她就像是在安详地睡着，随时都可能会醒来。维诺德亲吻了女儿的前额，告诉她他爱她，并说道：
Papa is here, Papa is here, I am so sorry, I have come to take you home. The arrangements to transport Annie's body back to the UK were made quickly and Vinod, Shreyan and Prakash were scheduled to fly home the following day. On Tuesday, November 16, the three men sat in the hotel reception waiting until it was time to go to the airport. Vinod noticed that Shreyan spent the majority of the time on his laptop or phone, disappearing once for about 10 minutes with an envelope and newspaper. When they flew home that afternoon, Shreyan slept for a majority of the flight, leaving
“爸爸在这里，爸爸在这里，我太难过了，我来接你回家了。”将安妮的遗体运回英国的安排很快就做好了，维诺德、什雷扬和普拉卡什计划于第二天飞回家。11 月 16 日星期二，三个男人坐在酒店大堂里，等待着去机场的时间。维诺德注意到什雷扬大部分时间都在用笔记本电脑或手机，中间曾拿着一个信封和一份报纸消失了大约 10 分钟。那天下午他们乘机回国时，什雷扬在大部分航程中都在睡觉，
Vinod without the chance to speak to him about what happened. In total, 25 fingerprints were found throughout Zollatongo's minivan and were scanned through the South African Police Service's automated fingerprint identification system. A left palm print on the right front fender returned 10 possible matches, which were manually compared to the original, resulting in a positive ID. 26-year-old unemployed laborer Kolele Mongani had been arrested five years earlier in 2005 on suspicion of killing a man in a bar fight. The charges against him were later dropped.
这让维诺德没有机会与他谈论究竟发生了什么。在佐拉·通戈的面包车里总共提取到了 25 枚指纹，并在南非警察局的自动指纹识别系统中进行了扫描。右前挡泥板上的一枚左手掌印比对出了 10 个可能的匹配项，经过人工与原始指纹的手工比对，得出了确切的身份结果。26 岁的失业零工科莱莱·蒙加尼（Kolele Mongani）曾在五年前的 2005 年因涉嫌在酒吧斗殴中杀害一名男子而被捕。对他的指控后来被撤销了。
On the morning of Tuesday, November 16, investigators tracked Mongani down to a shack located just a few hundred meters from where Zollatongo's minivan had been abandoned. Mongani had spent the previous night partying with friends and was found asleep in a bed with three other people. Police woke Mongani and read him his rights before placing him under arrest and conducting a search of the shack. Stuffed between the bed's mattress and its frame, they found a Nokia mobile phone. When asked who owned the phone, Mongani replied,
11 月 16 日星期二上午，调查人员顺藤摸瓜，在距离佐拉·通戈面包车被弃置地点仅几百米的一间棚屋里找到了蒙加尼。蒙加尼前一天晚上一直在和朋友们聚会狂欢，被发现时正和另外三人一起在一张床上呼呼大睡。警察唤醒蒙加尼，向他宣读了权利，随后将其逮捕并对棚屋进行了搜查。在床垫和床架之间，他们发现了一部诺基亚手机。当被问及这部手机属于谁时，蒙加尼回答说：
It belongs to the taxi driver. Hidden inside the shack's roof, police discovered Anise Georgiouamani watch and white gold bracelet. Mongani was taken in for questioning and soon admitted to being present for the carjacking and murder of Ani Hindochir. He denied being responsible for Ani's death, instead placing the blame on a man named Umsiwamadodakwabe. Mongani agreed to accompany the officers to various scenes of the crime and talk them through the events. He pointed out the locations where the minivan had been hijacked, where Zollatongo and Shri
“属于那个出租车司机。”藏在棚屋屋顶里的警察发现了安妮的乔治·阿玛尼手表和白金手链。蒙加尼被带去接受审讯，不久便承认自己参与了安妮·欣杜彻的劫车和谋杀案。他否认自己应对安妮的死负责，而是将罪责推给了一个名叫乌姆西瓦马多达夸贝（Umsiwamadodakwabe）的男子。蒙加尼同意陪同警察前往各个犯罪现场，并向他们还原了案发经过。他指出了面包车被劫持的位置、佐拉·通戈和什雷
and Dawani had been ejected and where stolen items had been hidden. The police then drove Mongani through the Kailisha township in an attempt to track down his alleged accomplice, Umsiwamadodakwabe, but were unable to locate him. Afterwards, Mongani was taken to the holding cells at the Directorate for Priority Crime Investigation in Belville. Two days later, on Thursday, November 18, police located alleged gunman, Umsiwamadodakwabe. The 27-year-old married father of three had no criminal record, but was known within the Kailisha township as being a small-time drug dealer.
扬·达瓦尼被赶下车的地点以及藏匿赃物的地点。随后，警察开车带着蒙加尼穿过凯利恰镇，试图追踪其同谋乌姆西瓦马多达夸贝，但未能找到他。之后，蒙加尼被关押在贝尔维尔（Belville）优先犯罪调查局（Directorate for Priority Crime Investigation）的拘留室里。两天后的 11 月 18 日星期四，警方锁定了涉嫌开枪的枪手乌姆西瓦马多达夸贝。这名 27 岁、已婚且育有三个孩子的男子没有犯罪前科，但在凯利恰镇当地是个小有名气的小毒贩。
Police took Kwabe in for questioning, where he quickly confessed to his involvement in the fatal carjacking. He also revealed the location of a 7.62mm Narinko pistol he had since offloaded to a friend and a drain where he had disposed of the cartridge from the bullet that had killed Ani Hindocha. Police were able to recover both items and confirm Kwabe's pistol to be the murder weapon. Despite confessing to a number of aspects relating to the crime, Kwabe insisted that he hadn't shot Ani and that it was his accomplice, Kolele Mongani, who had killed her. In a surprising twist, Kwabe claimed that he and Mongani had been recruited to carry out the
警方将夸贝带去审讯，他很快就供认了自己在这起致命劫车案中所扮演的角色。他还交代了一把 7.62 毫米北方工业（Norinco）手枪的下落，他已经将枪支转手给了一位朋友，并供出了扔掉杀死安妮·欣杜彻子弹弹壳的下水道。警方成功找回了这两件物品，并证实夸贝的手枪就是谋杀凶器。尽管对与案件相关的多个方面供认不讳，但夸贝坚称自己没有开枪打死安妮，并咬定是他的同谋科莱莱·蒙加尼杀害了安妮。令人意想不到的是，夸贝声称他和蒙加尼是被一个名叫蒙德·姆布隆博（Monde Mblombo）的男子以及在整个城市陪伴这对外国夫妇的出租车司机佐拉·通戈招募来实施这场
crime by a man named Monde Mblombo and the taxi driver who had been escorting the foreign couple throughout the city, Zola Tongo. 31-year-old Monde Mblombo worked at the reception desk of a luxury hotel called the Protea Coliseum Hotel. He and Kwabe had first met a decade earlier when they were both working with an educational project for youths from the Cape Flats townships. The two men had fallen out of touch in 2006 but suddenly bumped into one another again on November 1, 2010. They chatted for a while and exchanged phone numbers with Kwabe instructing Mblombo to call him if anyone was ever bothering him. Almost two weeks later, on Friday, November 12, Kwabe claimed Mblombo had called to say
犯罪的。31 岁的蒙德·姆布隆博在一家名为普罗蒂亚竞技场酒店（Protea Coliseum Hotel）的豪华酒店前台工作。他和夸贝十年前初次相识，当时两人都在为一个面向开普敦平原城镇青年的教育项目工作。两人在 2006 年失去了联系，但在 2010 年 11 月 1 日突然再次偶遇。他们聊了一会儿并交换了电话号码，夸贝还叮嘱姆布隆博如果以后有什么麻烦可以打电话给他。将近两周后的 11 月 12 日星期 Friday，夸贝称姆布隆博打电话说
he had a job that needed to be done and subsequently put Kwabe in contact with Tongo. On Thursday, November 18, police tracked Monde Mblombo down and placed him under arrest. He quickly confessed to his involvement with the carjacking and investigators then turned their attention to Zola Tongo, who they initially believed to have been a victim of the crime. That same day, Tongo retained the services of a lawyer, claiming he did so out of fear that the police planned to assault him. On Saturday, November 20, under advice from his lawyer, Tongo handed himself in. Meanwhile, Shreyan Dawani had requested that his wife's funeral be held in England so that his
他有一件需要去办的“差事”，随后将夸贝引荐给了通戈。11 月 18 日星期四，警方找到了蒙德·姆布隆博并将其逮捕。他很快对参与劫车供认不讳，随后调查人员将注意力转向了佐拉·通戈，而他们最初一直认为通戈是这起犯罪的受害者。同一天，通戈在律师的建议下聘请了辩护律师，称他这样做是出于害怕警方会对他动用私刑。11 月 20 日星期六，在律师的建议下，通戈主动投案自首。与此同时，什雷扬·达瓦尼要求将妻子的葬礼在英国举行，以便他的
family and friends could attend, and the hindoches agreed. In the lead-up to the event, several of Annie's loved ones noted that Shreyan was behaving strangely. Her father, Vinod, had noticed the peculiar behavior since Cape Town, where Shreyan had displayed little grief or tears over Annie's death and didn't voice a desire for his wife's killers to be caught. Instead, Shreyan had spent almost all of his time either on his laptop or mobile phone. The day before Annie's funeral, Shreyan informed the hindoches that a pizza party would be held in Annie's honour that night, which offended Vinod. Another clash also occurred at the funeral home. Hindu custom dictates that only women can dress the body of a deceased female,
家人和朋友能够出席，欣杜查家族对此表示同意。在活动筹备期间，安妮的一些亲友注意到什雷扬的行为有些古怪。她的父亲维诺德从开普敦起就注意到了这种诡异的举动，当时什雷扬对安妮的死表现得悲痛甚微、滴泪未沾，也没有表达出希望将妻子凶手绳之以法的愿望。相反，什雷扬几乎把所有时间都花在了笔记本电脑或手机上。在安妮葬礼的前一天，什雷扬通知欣杜查家族当晚将举办一场披萨派对来纪念安妮，这冒犯了维诺德。在殡仪馆里还发生了另一次冲突。印度教习俗规定，只有女性才能为女性死者净身穿衣，
so Annie's sister Ami and her cousin, Sneha, planned to undertake this role. Annie had been particularly close to Sneha, who was just one year younger than her. The pair were best friends since childhood, and when Annie moved to the UK, she had lived with Sneha. When Sneha and Ami arrived to dress Annie in preparation for her funeral, Shreyan was already there with his mother and aunt, which was highly unusual. During the dressing process, Shreyan shocked even his own relatives. Annie's parents had hoped to spend a few moments alone with Annie before her funeral, but when Ami asked Shreyan if this was possible, he refused. Ami later addressed the matter with the funeral director, who said the hindoches were welcome
因此安妮的姐姐阿米（Ami）和表妹斯内哈（Sneha）计划承担这一职责。安妮和斯内哈关系格外亲密，斯内哈只比她小一岁。两人从小就是至交好友，安妮搬到英国后就一直和斯内哈住在一起。当斯内哈和阿米赶来为安妮穿衣以筹备葬礼时，什雷扬已经和他的母亲及阿姨在那里了，这极其不寻常。在净身穿衣的过程中，什雷扬甚至惊呆了自己的亲戚。安妮的父母原本希望在葬礼前和安妮单独待一会儿，但当阿米问什雷扬这是否可行时，他拒绝了。阿米随后与殡仪馆负责人交涉，负责人表示欣杜查家族欢迎
to visit Annie's body 30 minutes prior to the ceremony. At 9.30 am on the day of the funeral, a number of Annie's relatives arrived to place letters they had written inside her coffin, and the family then held hands around her, taking it in turns to offer blessings. Annie was Vinod and Nelam's second child, born between eldest daughter Ami and son Anesh. In their Hindu faith, all women were considered to be the embodiment of the Goddess Lakshmi. As such, Vinod and Nelam considered Annie a blessing. She followed in her father's footsteps by pursuing a career in engineering and took a break from her studies in 2006 to take care of her mother after she was diagnosed with cancer. As Annie's parents and sister were
在仪式开始前 30 分钟瞻仰安妮的遗体。葬礼当天的上午 9 点 30 分，安妮的多位亲属抵达现场，将他们写好的信件放进棺材里，随后家属们手拉手围在棺材周围，轮流送上祝福。安妮是维诺德和内拉姆（Nelam）的第二个孩子，出生在大女儿阿米和儿子阿内什（Anesh）之间。在他们的印度教信仰中，所有女性都被认为是吉祥天女（Goddess Lakshmi）的化身。因此，维诺德和内拉姆视安妮为上天的赐福。她追随父亲的脚步追求工程学职业生涯，并在 2006 年暂停学业，悉心照顾被诊断出患有癌症的母亲。正当安妮的父母和姐姐在做
saying their final farewells, Shreyan suddenly burst in, shouting, What are you guys doing? You are not allowed to do this. An argument ensued until Shreyan's brother forced him to leave, but there wasn't enough time left for Ami to say goodbye to her sister. More than 150 mourners attended the service, during which Annie's family noticed that the letters they had placed in her coffin had been thrown onto the floor. It took some convincing to get Shreyan to agree to return them. A second memorial service was scheduled for the following day, but hostilities between Shreyan and the Hindochis continued when Shreyan threatened to cancel the event. He later agreed to let it proceed on the condition that Ami not be allowed
最后道别时，什雷扬突然冲进来，大喊道：“你们在干什么？你们不准这样做。”双方随即爆发争吵，直到什雷扬的兄弟强行将他拉走，但阿米已经没有足够的时间跟姐姐好好告别了。超过 150 名哀悼者出席了悼念仪式，在此期间，安妮的家人注意到他们放入棺材的信件被扔到了地上。经过一番劝说，什雷扬才终于同意将信件归还。第二场追悼会定于次日举行，但什雷扬和欣杜查家族之间的敌意仍在继续，什雷扬甚至威胁要取消这场活动。他后来同意让其继续进行，条件是不允许阿米
to address the mourners as he was upset by her behavior at the funeral. On Sunday, November 21, Annie's family were informed that in addition to the arrests of Mungeni, Kwaabe and Umblombo, taxi driver Zola Tongo had also been detained. That same day, Shreyan's brother Praianne phoned Vinod, urging him not to make the text messages that Annie had sent to Sneha public. Vinod had no idea what Praianne was referring to and was left baffled by the call. Later that day, an article in the independent newspaper quoted a South African police source as saying there would soon be an explosive revelation in the case. Following Annie's funeral, Shreyan hired the services of renowned British publicist Max Clifford,
向哀悼者发表讲话，因为他对阿米在葬礼上的行为感到不满。11 月 21 日星期日，安妮的家人得知，除了蒙加尼、夸贝和姆布隆博被捕外，出租车司机佐拉·通戈也被拘留了。同一天，什雷扬的兄弟普赖安（Praianne）打电话给维诺德，敦促他不要将安妮发给斯内哈的短信公之于众。维诺德根本不知道普赖安在说什么，对这通电话感到一头雾水。当天晚些时候，《独立报》的一篇报道援引南非警方消息人士的话称，该案很快将迎来爆炸性内幕。安妮的葬礼结束后，什雷扬聘请了英国知名公关人员马克斯·克利福德（Max Clifford），
who had previously represented high-profile clients including former NFL athlete and convicted felon O.J. Simpson, television personality and record executive Simon Cowell and English stand-up comedian Freddie Star. On Monday, November 22, it was requested that Annie's father Vinod attend a meeting at Max Clifford's office. Shreyan wasn't present for the meeting, but his brother Praianne was. Praianne recorded the meeting on his mobile phone, during which he asked Vinod such questions as, Do you like your son-in-law? Vinod found the entire experience to be strange and absurd. The next day of Tuesday, November 23, the promised explosive revelation in Annie's murder investigation was published in a number of English newspapers. According to reports, Umsi Wamadoda Kwaabe had
他曾代表过许多高调客户，包括前 NFL 运动员兼定罪重犯 O·J·辛普森（O.J. Simpson）、电视名人和唱片高管西蒙·考威尔（Simon Cowell）以及英国单口喜剧演员弗雷迪·斯塔尔（Freddie Star）。11 月 22 日星期一，有人要求安妮的父亲维诺德前往马克斯·克利福德的办公室参加会议。什雷扬没有出席这次会议，但他的兄弟普赖安出席了。普赖安用手机记录下了会议过程，并在期间向维诺德提出了诸如“你喜欢你的女婿吗？”之类的问题。维诺德觉得整个经历诡异而荒谬。第二天，即 11 月 23 日星期二，安妮谋杀案调查中承诺的“爆炸性内幕”在多家英国报纸上发表。据报道，乌姆西瓦马多达夸贝曾
told Cape Town Police that he and Kaulele Mongheny had been hired because, quote, there was a husband who wanted his wife to be killed. Almost immediately after Shreyan's possible involvement was made public, an article ran in tabloid newspaper The Daily Mail with the headline, Father of shot bride, I love Shreyan like a son. It was clear to Vinod that his recorded conversation with Praianne had been used for the peace. Shreyan defended himself publicly, telling the Sun newspaper, I searched high and low for my perfect partner. Annie was the one. Her looks, her laughter, her
向开普敦警方供述，他和考莱莱·蒙加尼被雇佣是因为“有一个丈夫想要杀掉他的妻子”。几乎在什雷扬可能涉案的消息公之于众后不久，《每日邮报》这本小报上就刊登了一篇文章，标题为《被枪杀新娘的父亲：我像爱儿子一样爱什雷扬》。维诺德很清楚，他和普赖安的录音对话被这篇文章利用了。什雷扬公开为自己辩护，对《太阳报》说：“我千方百计地寻找我的完美伴侣。安妮就是那个人。她的外表、她的笑声、她的”
personality, her spirit, everything about her was right for me. Why would I want to kill her? People who suggest this could not have seen us together. Saying I was somehow involved defies logic. Annie wasn't on any life insurance policies, and we hadn't even made a will. I had no motive, financial or otherwise. I loved her, and still love her. Shreyan also amended some of the details he had previously provided about the night of the carjacking. While he had initially told police that it was Annie's idea to visit the Cape Flats, he now claimed that it had been Tongo's suggestion, explaining, We were on our way home to our hotel when our driver asked whether we'd like to see
personality, her spirit, everything about her was right for me. Why would I want to kill her? People who suggest this could not have seen us together. Saying I was somehow involved defies logic. Annie wasn't on any life insurance policies, and we hadn't even made a will. I had no motive, financial or otherwise. I loved her, and still love her. Shreyan also amended some of the details he had previously provided about the night of the carjacking. While he had initially told police that it was Annie's idea to visit the Cape Flats, he now claimed that it had been Tongo's suggestion, explaining, We were on our way home to our hotel when our driver asked whether we'd like to see|||她的性格、她的精神，她的一切对我都再合适不过了。我为什么要杀她？那些这么认为的人一定没见过我们在一起的样子。说我某种程度上牵涉其中简直违背逻辑。安妮没有任何人寿保险，我们甚至连遗嘱都没立过。我没有任何动机，无论是在财务上还是其他方面。我爱她，现在依然爱她。施雷扬还修改了他之前提供的一些关于劫车当晚的细节。虽然他最初告诉警察是安妮主张去参观开普平地，但他现在声称那是通戈的建议，并解释道：“我们在回酒店的路上，司机问我们是否想在途中看看
some African dancing on our way. It was late, and we were hugging each other on the back seat, and going through photographs from the safari trip we'd just been on. We weren't really thinking of anything but each other, and sort of said, whatever. Although Shreyan had told police that he'd been forced out of the window of the moving van 20 minutes after Zola Tongo was ejected, he told the son that the vehicle had actually pulled over, more like 40 minutes after Tongo's release. When the carjack is realised, the child locks were activated and the back doors couldn't be opened, he had been dragged out of the window, kicking and screaming.
some African dancing on our way. It was late, and we were hugging each other on the back seat, and going through photographs from the safari trip we'd just been on. We weren't really thinking of anything but each other, and sort of said, whatever. Although Shreyan had told police that he'd been forced out of the window of the moving van 20 minutes after Zola Tongo was ejected, he told the son that the vehicle had actually pulled over, more like 40 minutes after Tongo's release. When the carjack is realised, the child locks were activated and the back doors couldn't be opened, he had been dragged out of the window, kicking and screaming.|||顺便看几场非洲舞蹈。当时已经很晚了，我们坐在后座上互相拥抱，翻看刚去过的野生动物园之旅的照片。我们脑子里除了彼此什么都没想，就随口说了句‘随便吧’。”尽管施雷扬曾告诉警方，在佐拉·通戈被赶下车20分钟后，他是从行驶的面包车车窗被强行推出去的，但他却对儿子说，实际上是在通戈离开大约40分钟后，车辆才靠边停车的。当劫车发生时，儿童锁被激活，后门无法打开，他是被踢打着、尖叫着从车窗拖出去的。
Shreyan claimed he was then thrown on the ground, and could do nothing but look on helplessly as the minivan disappeared with his wife inside. Annie's parents had long-harboured concerns about their daughter's relationship with Shreyan, beginning with the couple's engagement, which Vinod detailed in his book, Annie Diwani, a father's story. When Vinod and Nalaam were leaving Bristol after their initial meeting with Shreyan's family, the Diwani's had presented them with a large silver dish, known as a tarli, which was stuffed with fruits and nuts and had a bronze statue of Ganesh in the middle. In Hindu culture, this gift is traditionally presented to symbolise an engagement agreement
Shreyan claimed he was then thrown on the ground, and could do nothing but look on helplessly as the minivan disappeared with his wife inside. Annie's parents had long-harboured concerns about their daughter's relationship with Shreyan, beginning with the couple's engagement, which Vinod detailed in his book, Annie Diwani, a father's story. When Vinod and Nalaam were leaving Bristol after their initial meeting with Shreyan's family, the Diwani's had presented them with a large silver dish, known as a tarli, which was stuffed with fruits and nuts and had a bronze statue of Ganesh in the middle. In Hindu culture, this gift is traditionally presented to symbolise an engagement agreement|||施雷扬声称自己随后被扔在地上，眼睁睁地看着载着妻子的面包车消失却无能为力。安妮的父母长期以来一直对女儿与施雷扬的关系感到担忧，这种担忧始于两人的订婚，维诺德在他的书《安妮·迪瓦尼：一位父亲的故事》中对此进行了详细描述。当维诺德和娜拉姆在初次与施雷扬的家人会面后离开布里斯托尔时，迪瓦尼家族送给他们一个被称为“tarli”的大银盘，盘里塞满了水果和坚果，中间还有一尊象头神青铜雕像。在印度教文化中，传统上赠送这份礼物象征着订婚协议的达成。
between two parties. Vinod was confused about the gift, as he had only met Shreyan twice and would have preferred if the young man had approached in the traditional way. He would have also liked to have spoken with Annie first to see what she wanted. Not wanting to offend the Diwani's, he and Nalaam accepted the gift and departed for the airport. Annie had been equally caught off guard and spent weeks deliberating over what to do. Finally, in early May, she decided that she did want to marry Shreyan. After her final wedding reception, Annie had told her parents that she had been trying to convince Shreyan to take her to the Indian state of Kerala for their honeymoon,
between two parties. Vinod was confused about the gift, as he had only met Shreyan twice and would have preferred if the young man had approached in the traditional way. He would have also liked to have spoken with Annie first to see what she wanted. Not wanting to offend the Diwani's, he and Nalaam accepted the gift and departed for the airport. Annie had been equally caught off guard and spent weeks deliberating over what to do. Finally, in early May, she decided that she did want to marry Shreyan. After her final wedding reception, Annie had told her parents that she had been trying to convince Shreyan to take her to the Indian state of Kerala for their honeymoon,|||维诺德对这份礼物感到困惑，因为他只见过施雷扬两次，本希望这个年轻人能用传统的方式来提亲。他也希望先和安妮谈谈，看看她的意愿。为了不冒犯迪瓦尼家族，他和娜拉姆收下了礼物并前往机场。安妮同样感到措手不及，花了数周时间考虑该怎么做。最终，在5月初，她决定自己确实想嫁给施雷扬。在她的最后一场婚礼招待会后，安妮告诉父母，她曾试图说服施雷扬带她去印度的喀拉拉邦度蜜月，
so his choice of South Africa had seemed strange. When Shreyan had been implicated in Annie's murder, Annie's best friend and cousin, Snaya, revealed to the Hindochers that Annie and Shreyan had been having relationship problems for some time. She claimed that during the months they were in Mumbai planning their wedding, they had started arguing frequently. Annie had accused Shreyan of being possessive and controlling, and in turn, Shreyan had consistently reprimanded her over minor issues, such as how she placed her dirty clothing in the laundry basket. Prior to the couple's engagement, some of Annie's family members were told that Shreyan had health
so his choice of South Africa had seemed strange. When Shreyan had been implicated in Annie's murder, Annie's best friend and cousin, Snaya, revealed to the Hindochers that Annie and Shreyan had been having relationship problems for some time. She claimed that during the months they were in Mumbai planning their wedding, they had started arguing frequently. Annie had accused Shreyan of being possessive and controlling, and in turn, Shreyan had consistently reprimanded her over minor issues, such as how she placement her dirty clothing in the laundry basket. Prior to the couple's engagement, some of Annie's family members were told that Shreyan had health|||所以他选择南非显得有些奇怪。当施雷扬被牵连进安妮的谋杀案时，安妮的闺蜜兼表妹斯娜娅向欣多查一家透露，安妮和施雷扬的关系已经出现问题有一段时间了。她声称，在他们于孟买筹备婚礼的几个月里，两人开始频繁争吵。安妮指责施雷扬占有欲强且控制欲强，而施雷扬则不断因为一些小事斥责她，比如她把脏衣服放进洗衣篮的方式。在两人订婚之前，安妮的一些家庭成员被告知施雷扬有健康
problems and was receiving hormone treatments for infertility. However, Snaya told the Hindochers that Annie suspected this was a lie constructed by Shreyan to deflect from the fact that he had no sexual interest in her. Since the beginning of their relationship, they had slept in separate beds, leading Annie to worry that Shreyan didn't find her attractive. According to Snaya, Annie had repeatedly confided that she regretted getting engaged to Shreyan and had tried to call off the wedding on three occasions. Each time, Shreyan had persuaded her to change her mind. Annie expressed concern that she wouldn't find another partner and felt pressured by the amount of money her parents had already spent.
problems and was receiving hormone treatments for infertility. However, Snaya told the Hindochers that Annie suspected this was a lie constructed by Shreyan to deflect from the fact that he had no sexual interest in her. Since the beginning of their relationship, they had slept in separate beds, leading Annie to worry that Shreyan didn't find her attractive. According to Snaya, Annie had repeatedly confided that she regretted getting engaged to Shreyan and had tried to call off the wedding on three occasions. Each time, Shreyan had persuaded her to change her mind. Annie expressed concern that she wouldn't find another partner and felt pressured by the amount of money her parents had already spent.|||问题，并且正在接受治疗不孕不育的激素疗法。然而，斯娜娅告诉欣多查一家，安妮怀疑这是施雷扬编造的谎言，用来掩盖他对她没有性趣的事实。从他们恋爱之初起，他们就分床睡，这导致安妮担心施雷扬觉得她没有吸引力。据斯娜娅透露，安妮曾多次吐露心声，称自己后悔与施雷扬订婚，并曾三次试图取消婚礼。但每一次，施雷扬都说服她改变了主意。安妮担心自己找不到另一个伴侣，并且感到父母已经花费了大量金钱，这给她带来了压力。
Shortly before the wedding, she sent Snaya a text message that read, I don't want to marry him. I'm going to be unhappy for the rest of my life. One cannot even hug him. We have nothing in common. When the wedding ceremonies were underway, Annie told Snaya that she and Shreyan had decided to act happy even though they weren't. He showed no signs of returning to the funny and loving person he was when they first met, instead criticizing Annie's appearance and saying that one of her saris didn't look very proper. Annie hoped Shreyan's behavior would improve after the wedding and agreed to Snaya's suggestion to get a divorce if it didn't.
Shortly before the wedding, she sent Snaya a text message that read, I don't want to marry him. I'm going to be unhappy for the rest of my life. One cannot even hug him. We have nothing in common. When the wedding ceremonies were underway, Annie told Snaya that she and Shreyan had decided to act happy even though they weren't. He showed no signs of returning to the funny and loving person he was when they first met, instead criticizing Annie's appearance and saying that one of her saris didn't look very proper. Annie hoped Shreyan's behavior would improve after the wedding and agreed to Snaya's suggestion to get a divorce if it didn't.|||就在婚礼前不久，她给斯娜娅发了一条短信，上面写着：“我不想嫁给他。我余生都不会快乐的。甚至都不能拥抱他。我们没有任何共同点。”婚礼仪式进行期间，安妮告诉斯娜娅，她和施雷扬决定假装快乐，尽管他们并不快乐。他没有表现出一点要回到他们初次见面时那个风趣、充满爱意的人的迹象，反而开始挑剔安妮的外表，说她的一件纱丽看起来不太得体。安妮希望施雷扬在婚礼后的行为会有所改善，并同意了斯娜娅的建议：如果没改善就离婚。
When Annie learned that Shreyan would be taking her to South Africa for their honeymoon, she sent a text message to Snaya that read, I don't want to go anywhere with him. Snaya had urged Annie to go in an attempt to resolve the couple's issues and offered to send her money for a flight home if she was still unhappy a few days into the trip. After Annie arrived in South Africa, she messaged Snaya to say that the relationship was going better than before. In early December, Vinod Hindocha received a phone call from South African police requesting that he return to Cape Town as a matter of urgency.
When Annie learned that Shreyan would be taking her to South Africa for their honeymoon, she sent a text message to Snaya that read, I don't want to go anywhere with him. Snaya had urged Annie to go in an attempt to resolve the couple's issues and offered to send her money for a flight home if she was still unhappy a few days into the trip. After Annie arrived in South Africa, she messaged Snaya to say that the relationship was going better than before. In early December, Vinod Hindocha received a phone call from South African police requesting that he return to Cape Town as a matter of urgency.|||当安妮得知施雷扬要带她去南非度蜜月时，她给斯娜娅发了一条短信：“我不想跟他去任何地方。”斯娜娅曾力劝安妮去，试图借此解决两人的问题，并表示如果旅行几天后她仍然不开心，愿意出钱让她坐飞机回家。安妮到达南非后，给斯娜娅发信息说，两人的关系比以前更好了。12月初，维诺德·欣多查接到南非警察局的电话，要求他紧急返回开普敦。
Upon his arrival, investigators revealed that due to admissions made by taxi driver Zola Tongo, they had reason to believe that Shreyan had indeed orchestrated Annie's murder. According to Tongo, when he first picked the couple up from the Cape Town airport and dropped them at the Cape Grace Hotel, Annie went inside to the hotel lobby. Shreyan stayed behind and asked Tongo if he knew anyone who could help him take a client off the scene. The pair had a brief conversation in which Shreyan said he wanted to kill a woman who was arriving later that evening. He was willing to pay a hitman $15,000 or the equivalent of $2,185 Australian dollars at the time, in addition to paying a $5,000 grand finder's fee to Tongo.
Upon his arrival, investigators revealed that due to admissions made by taxi driver Zola Tongo, they had reason to believe that Shreyan had indeed orchestrated Annie's murder. According to Tongo, when he first picked the couple up from the Cape Town airport and dropped them at the Cape Grace Hotel, Annie went inside to the hotel lobby. Shreyan stayed behind and asked Tongo if he knew anyone who could help him take a client off the scene. The pair had a brief conversation in which Shreyan said he wanted to kill a woman who was arriving later that evening. He was willing to pay a hitman $15,000 or the equivalent of $2,185 Australian dollars at the time, in addition to paying a $5,000 grand finder's fee to Tongo.|||他抵达后，调查人员透露，根据出租车司机佐拉·通戈的供述，他们有理由相信施雷扬确实策划了安妮的谋杀。据通戈供述，当他第一次从开普敦机场接上这对夫妇并把他们送到开普格雷斯酒店时，安妮先走进了酒店大堂。施雷扬留在车后，问通戈是否认识能帮他做掉一个客户的人。两人进行了简短的交谈，施雷扬说他想杀一个将于当晚晚些时候抵达的女人。他愿意向杀手支付15,000美元（相当于当时的2,185澳元），此外还要支付给通戈5,000美元的巨额介绍费。
He also offered to pay using American dollars if that was preferable. Although Tongo had virtually no criminal record, with the exception of one conviction for driving without a taxi permit, he had agreed to put Shreyan in touch with someone who could commit the crime. Investigators checked security footage captured outside the hotel, and confirmed that Shreyan had spoken with Tongo during this time period, while Annie waited at the lobby's check-in desk. Shreyan then went inside to join his wife, but soon came back outside, where he spoke to Tongo for a further nine minutes. Tongo claimed that after leaving the Cape Grace, he called the Protea Coliseum Hotel, where his friend Monde Mblombo worked at the reception desk.
He also offered to pay using American dollars if that was preferable. Although Tongo had virtually no criminal record, with the exception of one conviction for driving without a taxi permit, he had agreed to put Shreyan in touch with someone who could commit the crime. Investigators checked security footage captured outside the hotel, and confirmed that Shreyan had spoken with Tongo during this time period, while Annie waited at the lobby's check-in desk. Shreyan then went inside to join his wife, but soon came back outside, where he spoke to Tongo for a further nine minutes. Tongo claimed that after leaving the Cape Grace, he called the Protea Coliseum Hotel, where his friend Monde Mblombo worked at the reception desk.|||他还提出如果对方愿意，可以用美元支付。尽管通戈几乎没有犯罪记录（除了曾因无出租车运营证驾驶而被定罪一次外），但他还是同意帮施雷扬联系能犯罪的人。调查人员查看了酒店外捕捉到的监控录像，确认施雷扬在安妮于大堂前台等待期间确实与通戈交谈过。随后，施雷扬走进酒店与妻子会合，但很快又走了出来，并在那里与通戈交谈了整整九分钟。通戈声称，在离开开普格雷斯酒店后，他打电话给帝王花竞技场酒店，他的朋友蒙德·姆布隆博在那里前台工作。
CCTV footage showed Mblombo had answered the call, followed by Tongo's arrival at the Protea Coliseum approximately 25 minutes later. There, Tongo greeted Mblombo by placing both hands on top of his head, a gesture that indicated cause for celebration, and the two left to speak together. According to Tongo, he had informed Mblombo of Shreyan's request, and Mblombo said he knew a suitable person who could carry out the crime. The conversation lasted just two and a half minutes, then Mblombo put Tongo in touch with his old friend, Umsiwama Dota Kwaabe. That evening, Tongo had phoned Kwaabe to ask if he could do the job. Kwaabe was with his friend, Kōlile Mungeni when the call came through,
CCTV footage showed Mblombo had answered the call, followed by Tongo's arrival at the Protea Coliseum approximately 25 minutes later. There, Tongo greeted Mblombo by placing both hands on top of his head, a gesture that indicated cause for celebration, and the two left to speak together. According to Tongo, he had informed Mblombo of Shreyan's request, and Mblombo said he knew a suitable person who could carry out the crime. The conversation lasted just two and a half minutes, then Mblombo put Tongo in touch with his old friend, Umsiwama Dota Kwaabe. That evening, Tongo had phoned Kwaabe to ask if he could do the job. Kwaabe was with his friend, Kōlile Mungeni when the call came through,|||闭路电视监控录像显示姆布隆博接了电话，大约25分钟后通戈抵达了帝王花竞技场酒店。在那里，通戈把双手放在头顶上向姆布隆博打招呼，这是一个表示值得庆祝的手势，随后两人离开并交谈起来。据通戈所说，他将施雷扬的要求告诉了姆布隆博，姆布隆博说他认识一个能够执行此罪行的合适人选。对话仅持续了两分半钟，随后姆布隆博将通戈介绍给了他的老朋友乌姆西瓦马·多塔·夸贝。当晚，通戈打电话给夸贝，询问他是否能接这桩活。当电话打进来时，夸贝正和他的朋友科利莱·姆恩盖尼在一起，
and the two men agreed to participate in the plot. The same night that Tongo conspired with Kwaabe, Annie and Shreyan had dined at a waterfront restaurant located a short walk from their hotel. A waitress told investigators that she had approached the couple's table at around 9.20pm. Annie was sitting there alone, and explained that her husband had left to make a business call. CCTV footage from this time captured Shreyan walking the short distance back to the couple's hotel room, where he had left his mobile phone. His phone records revealed that he had received a text message from Tongo, though its contents are unknown. Shreyan called Tongo, and the pair
and the two men agreed to participate in the plot. The same night that Tongo conspired with Kwaabe, Annie and Shreyan had dined at a waterfront restaurant located a short walk from their hotel. A waitress told investigators that she had approached the couple's table at around 9.20pm. Annie was sitting there alone, and explained that her husband had left to make a business call. CCTV footage from this time captured Shreyan walking the short distance back to the couple's hotel room, where he had left his mobile phone. His phone records revealed that he had received a text message from Tongo, though its contents are unknown. Shreyan called Tongo, and the pair|||两人同意参与这个阴谋。就在通戈与夸贝密谋的当晚，安妮和施雷扬在距离酒店步行不远的一家海滨餐厅共进晚餐。一名女服务员告诉调查人员，她在晚上9点20分左右走近这对夫妇的桌子。安妮独自坐在那里，解释说她丈夫出去打商务电话了。当时的闭路电视监控录像捕捉到施雷扬步行一小段路返回两人的酒店房间，他把手机忘在那里了。他的通话记录显示他收到了通戈发来的短信，但内容不明。施雷扬给通戈回了电话，两人
spoke for 5 minutes and 26 seconds. Tongo told investigators that during the call, he updated Shreyan on the progress of the hit, and confirmed that the hitmen wished to be paid in Rand. He then agreed to help Shreyan exchange some US currency into South African Rand the following day. At 11.56am on Saturday, November 13, CCTV footage from the Kwaabe Grace Hotel captured Tongo picking Shreyan up in his minivan. The pair then drove to a jewelry store called Golden Touch Jewelers, where Shreyan exchanged US$1,500 for 10,200 Rand. Police later confirmed this exchange with the store's owner. Tongo told investigators that on the drive back to the hotel, he and Shreyan discussed the plans for the murder, and determined the order in which the two of them
spoke for 5 minutes and 26 seconds. Tongo told investigators that during the call, he updated Shreyan on the progress of the hit, and confirmed that the hitmen wished to be paid in Rand. He then agreed to help Shreyan exchange some US currency into South African Rand the following day. At 11.56am on Saturday, November 13, CCTV footage from the Kwaabe Grace Hotel captured Tongo picking Shreyan up in his minivan. The pair then drove to a jewelry store called Golden Touch Jewelers, where Shreyan exchanged US$1,500 for 10,200 Rand. Police later confirmed this exchange with the store's owner. Tongo told investigators that on the drive back to the hotel, he and Shreyan discussed the plans for the murder, and determined the order in which the two of them|||交谈了5分26秒。通戈告诉调查人员，在通话期间，他向施雷扬通报了行刺进展，并确认杀手希望以兰特支付报酬。随后他同意第二天帮施雷扬将一些美元兑换成南非兰特。11月13日星期六上午11点56分，夸贝格雷斯酒店的监控录像拍到通戈用他的面包车接走了施雷扬。两人随后开车前往一家名为“金手指珠宝”的珠宝店，施雷扬在那里用1,500美元兑换了10,200兰特。警方后来向该店店主证实了这笔兑换。通戈告诉调查人员，在开车回酒店的路上，他和施雷扬讨论了谋杀计划，并确定了他们两人
would be released from the hijacked minivan. With this new information from Tongo, South African authorities intended to prosecute Shreyan for Annie's murder. They asked Annie's father, Vinod, whether he would agree to a plea deal for Tongo, in which he would plead guilty and testify against Shreyan in exchange for a reduced sentence. Vinod agonized over the decision. He believed that if Tongo was responsible for hiring the men who killed his daughter, then he deserved to spend the rest of his life in prison. However, after much consideration, Vinod agreed to the request, and Tongo's plea deal was formalized on December 5, 2010. On Tuesday, December 7, Zola Tongo appeared in the Western Cape High Court to make his plea, stating,
would be released from the hijacked minivan. With this new information from Tongo, South African authorities intended to prosecute Shreyan for Annie's murder. They asked Annie's father, Vinod, whether he would agree to a plea deal for Tongo, in which he would plead guilty and testify against Shreyan in exchange for a reduced sentence. Vinod agonized over the decision. He believed that if Tongo was responsible for hiring the men who killed his daughter, then he deserved to spend the rest of his life in prison. However, after much consideration, Vinod agreed to the request, and Tongo's plea deal was formalized on December 5, 2010. On Tuesday, December 7, Zola Tongo appeared in the Western Cape High Court to make his plea, stating,|||将从被劫持的面包车中被释放的先后顺序。有了通戈提供的这些新信息，南非当局打算以谋杀安妮的罪名起诉施雷扬。他们征求安妮的父亲维诺德的意见，问他是否同意与通戈达成认罪协议——通戈将认罪并出庭作证指证施雷扬，以此换取减刑。维诺德对这个决定感到痛苦万分。他认为，如果通戈负责雇佣杀害他女儿的人，那么他理应在监狱里度过余生。然而，经过深思熟虑，维诺德同意了这一请求，通戈的认罪协议于2010年12月5日正式敲定。12月7日星期二，佐拉·通戈出现在西开普高等法院进行抗辩，并陈述道：
I knew that Mungeni and Quabe would not harm Shreyan DeWani and that he would be dropped off at some further point. I also knew that the deceased would be kidnapped, robbed, and murdered by Quabe and Mungeni. Tongo pleaded guilty to kidnapping, robbery with aggravating circumstances, murder, and obstructing the administration of justice. As per his agreed plea deal, he was sentenced to 18 years in prison. Immediately after Tongo's testimony, the South African Police Service forwarded an arrest warrant for Shreyan DeWani to the Foreign Assistance Division of Scotland Yard in London. Word about the warrant reached Shreyan at his family home, and by the end of the day,
I knew that Mungeni and Quabe would not harm Shreyan DeWani and that he would be dropped off at some further point. I also knew that the deceased would be kidnapped, robbed, and murdered by Quabe and Mungeni. Tongo pleaded guilty to kidnapping, robbery with aggravating circumstances, murder, and obstructing the administration of justice. As per his agreed plea deal, he was sentenced to 18 years in prison. Immediately after Tongo's testimony, the South African Police Service forwarded an arrest warrant for Shreyan DeWani to the Foreign Assistance Division of Scotland Yard in London. Word about the warrant reached Shreyan at his family home, and by the end of the day,|||“我知道姆恩盖尼和夸贝不会伤害施雷扬·迪瓦尼，他会在稍远一点的地方被放下车。我也知道死者会被夸贝和姆恩盖尼绑架、抢劫和杀害。”通戈对绑架、加重情节抢劫、谋杀以及妨碍司法公正罪名表示认罪。根据他达成的认罪协议，他被判处18年监禁。在通戈作证后不久，南非警察局将针对施雷扬·迪瓦尼的逮捕令转交给伦敦苏格兰场的外事处。逮捕令的消息传到了位于其家族住所的施雷扬那里，到了当天结束时，
he handed himself in to police and was arrested on suspicion of conspiracy to commit murder. Three days later, Shreyan appeared in the United Kingdom's High Court. He was granted a bail on the condition that he wear an electronic tag, comply with the curfew, and report daily to police pending extradition hearings, which were scheduled for early 2011. Shreyan maintained his innocence with his lawyer issuing a public statement that read, My client is devastated by Annie's murder and the false allegations that have been made against him, and welcomes the chance to clear his name through the courts. Shreyan's arrest was major news in South Africa, where the nation's media accused him of trying
he handed himself in to police and was arrested on suspicion of conspiracy to commit murder. Three days later, Shreyan appeared in the United Kingdom's High Court. He was granted a bail on the condition that he wear an electronic tag, comply with the curfew, and report daily to police pending extradition hearings, which were scheduled for early 2011. Shreyan maintained his innocence with his lawyer issuing a public statement that read, My client is devastated by Annie's murder and the false allegations that have been made against him, and welcomes the chance to clear his name through the courts. Shreyan's arrest was major news in South Africa, where the nation's media accused him of trying|||他向警方自首，并因涉嫌谋杀阴谋而被捕。三天后，施雷扬出现在英国高等法院。他获得保释，条件是必须佩戴电子标签、遵守宵禁规定，并在等待原定于2011年初举行的引渡听证会期间每天向警方报到。施雷扬坚称自己无罪，他的律师发表了一份公开声明：“我的客户对安妮的谋杀案以及针对他的虚假指控感到痛心疾首，并欢迎通过法庭洗清自己罪名的机会。”施雷扬被捕是南非的一条重大新闻，该国媒体指责他企图
to exploit the country's high murder rate by having his wife killed there. Almost six months earlier, South Africa had hosted the world's most prestigious international soccer competition, the FIFA World Cup, prompting over 300,000 tourists to flock to the country. Annie's murder reignited old concerns that South Africa would be perceived by foreigners as a dangerous place. Some of the nation's public figures shared their concerns, with a representative from the Congress of South African Trade Unions stating, Annie Hindoche's murder appears to have been planned on the assumption that hijacking and murder are believed to be so commonplace that it would be easy to stage a murder and then claim it was
to exploit the country's high murder rate by having his wife killed there. Almost six months earlier, South Africa had hosted the world's most prestigious international soccer competition, the FIFA World Cup, prompting over 300,000 tourists to flock to the country. Annie's murder reignited old concerns that South Africa would be perceived by foreigners as a dangerous place. Some of the nation's public figures shared their concerns, with a representative from the Congress of South African Trade Unions stating, Annie Hindoche's murder appears to have been planned on the assumption that hijacking and murder are believed to be so commonplace that it would be easy to stage a murder and then claim it was|||利用该国的高谋杀率，在那里让人杀害他的妻子。就在大约六个月前，南非刚刚举办了世界上最负盛名的国际足球赛事——国际足联世界杯，吸引了超过30万名游客涌入该国。安妮的谋杀案再次引发了人们对南非会被外国人视为危险之地的旧忧。该国的一些公众人物也表达了他们的担忧，南非工会大会的一位代表表示：“安妮·欣多查的谋杀案似乎是在这样一种假设下策划的：人们认为劫车和谋杀是如此司空见惯，以至于伪造一场谋杀然后声称那是
another normal criminal act. On Wednesday, December 15, another twist in the case emerged, when a German man who lived in England's Midlands region came forward, claiming to have had sex with Shreyan Dewany on three separate occasions. Leopold Leiser, a 39-year-old sex worker known as the German master, alleged that Shreyan had paid him 1100 pounds in cash for his services between September 2009 and April 2010, one month before Shreyan and Annie got engaged. According to Leopold, Shreyan had told him about his forthcoming wedding to Annie, stating that although she was a nice girl, he needed to, quote, find a way out. Shreyan was worried that his family would disown him if he called off the wedding.
another normal criminal act. On Wednesday, December 15, another twist in the case emerged, when a German man who lived in England's Midlands region came forward, claiming to have had sex with Shreyan Dewany on three separate occasions. Leopold Leiser, a 39-year-old sex worker known as the German master, alleged that Shreyan had paid him 1100 pounds in cash for his services between September 2009 and April 2010, one month before Shreyan and Annie got engaged. According to Leopold, Shreyan had told him about his forthcoming wedding to Annie, stating that although she was a nice girl, he needed to, quote, find a way out. Shreyan was worried that his family would disown him if he called off the wedding.|||另一起普通的刑事案件会非常容易。”12月15日星期三，案件迎来了另一个转折：一名住在英国中部地区的德国男子主动现身，声称自己曾与施雷扬·迪瓦尼发生过三次性关系。莱奥波德·莱瑟是一名39岁的性工作者，被称为“德国大师”，他声称施雷扬在2009年9月至2010年4月（即施雷扬和安妮订婚前一个月）期间，曾为其服务支付过1100英镑的现金。据莱奥波德所说，施雷扬曾向他讲述了自己即将与安妮举行的婚礼，并表示虽然安妮是个好女孩，但他需要“找一条出路”。施雷扬担心如果自己取消婚礼，家人会与他断绝关系。
These allegations led to speculation that Shreyan's sexuality could have motivated him to order Annie's murder. His lawyer labelled Leopold's claims as completely false and ridiculous, and his publicist Max Clifford stated, Shreyan Dewany has never had a sexual relationship with a man in his life. In Cape Town, prosecutors negotiated with the suspects they already had in custody, and struck a plea deal with one of the two accused carjackers, Umsiwamadoda Kwaabe. Kwaabe had initially pleaded not guilty to Annie's murder, claiming he hadn't been the one who shot her. He changed his mind upon learning that under South African law, being a co-conspirator
These allegations led to speculation that Shreyan's sexuality could have motivated him to order Annie's murder. His lawyer labelled Leopold's claims as completely false and ridiculous, and his publicist Max Clifford stated, Shreyan Dewany has never had a sexual relationship with a man in his life. In Cape Town, prosecutors negotiated with the suspects they already had in custody, and struck a plea deal with one of the two accused carjackers, Umsiwamadoda Kwaabe. Kwaabe had initially pleaded not guilty to Annie's murder, claiming he hadn't been the one who shot her. He changed his mind upon learning that under South African law, being a co-conspirator|||这些指控引发了人们的猜测，即施雷扬的性取向可能是他下令谋杀安妮的动机。他的律师将莱奥波德的说法斥为完全虚假和荒谬，他的公关人员马克斯·克利福德则表示：“施雷扬·迪瓦尼这辈子从未与男性发生过性关系。”在开普敦，检察官与已经被拘留的嫌疑人进行了谈判，并与两名被指控的劫车犯之一——乌姆西瓦马多达·夸贝达成了认罪协议。夸贝最初对谋杀安妮的罪名拒不认罪，声称开枪打死她的人不是他。但在得知根据南非法律，作为共同谋划者
to the crimes he had already confessed to, made him equally guilty of Annie's murder. In exchange for a reduced sentence of 25 years, with a 17-year minimum, Kwaabe agreed to testify against Shreyan, and pleaded guilty to charges of kidnapping, a legal possession of a firearm, robbery with aggravating circumstances, and murder. Kwaabe confessed that on November 12, 2010, he received a phone call from his old friend Monde Mblombo, who said that a job needed to be done. He then spoke directly with Zola Tongo, who explained that someone had ordered a hit, and Kwaabe subsequently recruited his friend, Kaulile Mungeni, to help. The following day, the trio met up, and Tongo told Kwaabe and Mungeni
to the crimes he had already confessed to, made him equally guilty of Annie's murder. In exchange for a reduced sentence of 25 years, with a 17-year minimum, Kwaabe agreed to testify against Shreyan, and pleaded guilty to charges of kidnapping, a legal possession of a firearm, robbery with aggravating circumstances, and murder. Kwaabe confessed that on November 12, 2010, he received a phone call from his old friend Monde Mblombo, who said that a job needed to be done. He then spoke directly with Zola Tongo, who explained that someone had ordered a hit, and Kwaabe subsequently recruited his friend, Kaulile Mungeni, to help. The following day, the trio met up, and Tongo told Kwaabe and Mungeni|||对他已经承认的罪行同样负有谋杀安妮的罪责后，他改变了主意。作为减刑至25年（其中最低服刑17年）的交换条件，夸贝同意出庭指证施雷扬，并对绑架、非法持有枪支、加重情节抢劫和谋杀罪名表示认罪。夸贝供认，2010年11月12日，他接到老朋友蒙德·姆布隆博的电话，说有一桩活需要干。随后他直接与佐拉·通戈交谈，通戈解释说有人买凶杀人，夸贝随后招募了他的朋友考利莱·姆恩盖尼来帮忙。第二天，三人碰面了，通戈告诉夸贝和姆恩盖尼，
that a husband wanted his wife killed in a staged hijacking. In exchange for 1500 rand, they agreed that the husband would be unharmed, and that the wife would be kidnapped, robbed, and killed. Payment for the hit was to be left inside the glove box of the minivan. Kwaabe told investigators that during the course of the hijacking, he drove the minivan while Mungeni sat in the front passenger seat, brandishing the gun. After robbing the newlyweds and forcing Tongo and Shreyan from the vehicle, Mungeni shot and killed Annie from the front passenger seat. Kwaabe and Mungeni then dumped the car, and Kwaabe gave the gun to a friend for safekeeping. Monde Mblombo confessed to acting as an intermediary
that a husband wanted his wife killed in a staged hijacking. In exchange for 1500 rand, they agreed that the husband would be unharmed, and that the wife would be kidnapped, robbed, and killed. Payment for the hit was to be left inside the glove box of the minivan. Kwaabe told investigators that during the course of the hijacking, he drove the minivan while Mungeni sat in the front passenger seat, brandishing the gun. After robbing the newlyweds and forcing Tongo and Shreyan from the vehicle, Mungeni shot and killed Annie from the front passenger seat. Kwaabe and Mungeni then dumped the car, and Kwaabe gave the gun to a friend for safekeeping. Monde Mblombo confessed to acting as an intermediary|||一个丈夫想要在一场自导自演的劫车案中杀害他的妻子。作为1500兰特的报酬，他们同意保证丈夫不受伤害，而妻子则将被绑架、抢劫并杀害。买凶杀人的报酬将留在面包车的杂物箱里。夸贝告诉调查人员，在劫车过程中，他驾驶着面包车，而姆恩盖尼则坐在副驾驶座上，挥舞着枪。在抢劫了新婚夫妇并迫使通戈和施雷扬下车后，姆恩盖尼坐在副驾驶座上开枪打死了安妮。随后，夸贝和姆恩盖尼扔掉了汽车，夸贝把枪交给了一个朋友代为保管。蒙德·姆布隆博供认自己充当了中间人，
between Tongo and Kwaabe, but prosecutors believed his role had been minimal, and therefore he wasn't charged with any crime. Instead, Mblombo was offered immunity in exchange for testifying at Shreyan's trial, as well as that of Kohlele Mungeni, the only one of the South African suspects who had refused the plea deal, and elected to plead not guilty. Meanwhile, in England, proceedings were underway to determine whether Shreyan Dewani would have to return to South Africa to face the accusations levelled against him. South African authorities argued that Shreyan's alleged involvement in the crime explained why he had employed a local taxi driver instead of using his hotel's airport shuttle service, and also explained how he had escaped from the hijackers
between Tongo and Kwaabe, but prosecutors believed his role had been minimal, and therefore he wasn't charged with any crime. Instead, Mblombo was offered immunity in exchange for testifying at Shreyan's trial, as well as that of Kohlele Mungeni, the only one of the South African suspects who had refused the plea deal, and elected to plead not guilty. Meanwhile, in England, proceedings were underway to determine whether Shreyan Dewani would have to return to South Africa to face the accusations levelled against him. South African authorities argued that Shreyan's alleged involvement in the crime explained why he had employed a local taxi driver instead of using his hotel's airport shuttle service, and also explained how he had escaped from the hijackers|||在通戈和夸贝之间牵线搭桥，但检察官认为他的作用微乎其微，因此没有对其实施任何犯罪指控。相反，姆布隆博获得了豁免权，条件是在施雷扬的审判以及科勒莱·姆恩盖尼的审判中出庭作证——科勒莱是南非嫌疑人中唯一一个拒绝认罪协议并选择做无罪抗辩的人。与此同时，在英国，相关法律程序正在进行中，以决定施雷扬·迪瓦尼是否必须返回南非面对针对他的指控。南非当局辩称，施雷扬涉嫌参与这起犯罪，这解释了他为什么会雇佣当地的出租车司机，而不是使用酒店的机场穿梭巴士服务，同时也解释了他如何能从劫匪手中
unscathed. In response, Shreyan supporters stated it was ludicrous to believe he had asked the first person he met in Cape Town to kill his wife. A preliminary extradition hearing was initially scheduled for February 2011, but Shreyan failed to appear, citing mental illness. The court was told that he had consumed 46 different pills, though Shreyan's doctor denied this had been a suicide attempt. Two months later, on April 20, 2011, Shreyan was detained at a Bristol psychiatric hospital under the Mental Health Act. His defense team continued to fight the extradition process, claiming that their client was mentally unfit to stand trial. They also argued that Shreyan would face a violent sexual assault and the risk of HIV
unscathed. In response, Shreyan supporters stated it was ludicrous to believe he had asked the first person he met in Cape Town to kill his wife. A preliminary extradition hearing was initially scheduled for February 2011, but Shreyan failed to appear, citing mental illness. The court was told that he had consumed 46 different pills, though Shreyan's doctor denied this had been a suicide attempt. Two months later, on April 20, 2011, Shreyan was detained at a Bristol psychiatric hospital under the Mental Health Act. His defense team continued to fight the extradition process, claiming that their client was mentally unfit to stand trial. They also argued that Shreyan would face a violent sexual assault and the risk of HIV|||毫发无损地逃脱。对此，施雷扬的支持者表示，认为他会叫自己在开普敦遇到的第一个人去杀他的妻子简直荒谬绝伦。初步的引渡听证会原定于2011年2月举行，但施雷扬以患有精神疾病为由未出庭。法庭被告知他服用了46种不同的药丸，不过施雷扬的医生否认这是自杀未遂。两个月后的2011年4月20日，施雷扬根据《精神健康法》被拘留在布里斯托尔的一家精神病院。他的辩护团队继续反对引渡程序，声称他们的客户精神状况不适合接受审判。他们还辩称，施雷扬如果在南非监狱服刑，将面临严重的性侵犯和感染艾滋病毒的
infection in a South African prison. Nevertheless, on August 10, 2011, British judge Howard Riddle ruled that Shreyan should be extradited, stating that he had confidence in the South African justice system. The paperwork was sent to the UK's immigration minister and then Home Secretary Theresa May for final approval. The Hindocha family presented a petition featuring more than 11,000 signatures to Theresa May, urging her to agree to the extradition. On September 28, 2011, May agreed that the extradition order was valid and that Shreyan should be sent to Cape Town. Despite South African officials making assurances that Shreyan's health would be protected, his legal team continued to insist he was not mentally fit to make the journey.
infection in a South African prison. Nevertheless, on August 10, 2011, British judge Howard Riddle ruled that Shreyan should be extradited, stating that he had confidence in the South African justice system. The paperwork was sent to the UK's immigration minister and then Home Secretary Theresa May for final approval. The Hindocha family presented a petition featuring more than 11,000 signatures to Theresa May, urging her to agree to the extradition. On September 28, 2011, May agreed that the extradition order was valid and that Shreyan should be sent to Cape Town. Despite South African officials making assurances that Shreyan's health would be protected, his legal team continued to insist he was not mentally fit to make the journey.|||风险。尽管如此，2011年8月10日，英国法官霍华德·里德尔裁定应当将施雷扬引渡，并表示他对南非的司法系统充满信心。相关文件被送交英国移民大臣以及时任内政大臣特雷莎·梅以进行最终批准。欣多查家族向特雷莎·梅提交了一份征集了11,000多个签名的请愿书，敦促她同意引渡。2011年9月28日，梅同意引渡令有效，并决定将施雷扬送往开普敦。尽管南非官员保证施雷扬的健康将得到保护，但他的法律团队仍然坚称他在精神上不适合进行这次旅行。
Ultimately, England's High Court agreed that Shreyan should remain in the UK until his health improved. The drawn-out process took an emotional toll on the Hindocha family. On November 13, 2011, they held a candlelit vigil in their hometown of Mariestod to commemorate the one-year anniversary of Annie's murder. While the extradition hearings continued, on March 29, 2012, BBC Current Affairs Programme Panorama broadcast an hour-long feature about the hijacking case titled, The Honeymoon Murder. In the episode, experts examined the evidence collected by South African police and discovered a number of inconsistencies, particularly in relation to the state's forensic evidence.
Ultimately, England's High Court agreed that Shreyan should remain in the UK until his health improved. The drawn-out process took an emotional toll on the Hindocha family. On November 13, 2011, they held a candlelit vigil in their hometown of Mariestod to commemorate the one-year anniversary of Annie's murder. While the extradition hearings continued, on March 29, 2012, BBC Current Affairs Programme Panorama broadcast an hour-long feature about the hijacking case titled, The Honeymoon Murder. In the episode, experts examined the evidence collected by South African police and discovered a number of inconsistencies, particularly in relation to the state's forensic evidence.|||最终，英国高等法院同意施雷扬留在英国，直到他的健康状况有所改善。这场旷日持久的法律程序给欣多查家族带来了沉重的精神打击。2011年11月13日，他们在自己的家乡玛丽斯塔德举行了烛光晚会，纪念安妮遇害一周年。在引渡听证会持续进行的同时，2012年3月29日，BBC时事节目《广角镜》播出了一个关于劫车案的长达一小时的专题节目，名为《蜜月谋杀案》。在该节目中，专家们检查了南非警方收集的证据，发现许多前后矛盾之处，特别是在该国的法医证据方面。
Annie's autopsy stated that she had likely been cowering in a defensive posture at the time of her death. But when UK Home Office pathologist Dr Richard Shepard viewed the case file, he found no evidence to indicate such a thing. Instead, Dr Shepard believed that the lack of blood spatter on the back of the passenger seat suggested Annie had been sitting up and leaning forward at the time she was killed. Additionally, the two hijackers had each presented a different story as to how Annie was killed. Upon Kulile Mungeni's arrest, he had claimed that Umsiwamadoda Kwaabe had approached Annie via the rear passenger door and shot her during a tussle over her handbag. Kwaabe denied this version of events, claiming that Mungeni had shot Annie
Annie's autopsy stated that she had likely been cowering in a defensive posture at the time of her death. But when UK Home Office pathologist Dr Richard Shepard viewed the case file, he found no evidence to indicate such a thing. Instead, Dr Shepard believed that the lack of blood spatter on the back of the passenger seat suggested Annie had been sitting up and leaning forward at the time she was killed. Additionally, the two hijackers had each presented a different story as to how Annie was killed. Upon Kulile Mungeni's arrest, he had claimed that Umsiwamadoda Kwaabe had approached Annie via the rear passenger door and shot her during a tussle over her handbag. Kwaabe denied this version of events, claiming that Mungeni had shot Annie|||安妮的尸检报告称，她在死亡时可能正处于防御姿态的瑟缩状态。但当英国内政部病理学家理查德·谢帕德博士查看案卷时，他没有发现任何证据表明这一点。相反，谢帕德博士认为，副驾驶座靠背上缺乏血迹飞溅表明安妮在遇害时是坐着并向前倾身的。此外，两名劫匪对安妮是如何被杀的各执一词。库利莱·姆恩盖尼被捕后，曾声称乌姆西瓦马多达·夸贝是从后排乘客车门接近安妮，并在争夺手提包的过程中开枪射杀她的。夸贝否认了这种说法，声称是姆恩盖尼开枪打死了安妮，
while he was sitting in the front passenger seat, a claim that was later deemed to be incompatible with the forensic evidence. South African investigators had concluded that Annie had been killed by a bullet fired from between 5 and 10 centimetres away. This was contested on Panorama by Mark Mestaglio, a leading firearms expert at the UK's Forensic Science Service. He found that the size and pattern of the gunshot and residue indicated a firing position of less than 5 centimetres. Mestaglio suspected that the gun went off when pressed right up against Annie, perhaps during a struggle. Angela Shaw, one of the UK's leading experts on gunshot residue, told Panorama that the South African police had failed to test
while he was sitting in the front passenger seat, a claim that was later deemed to be incompatible with the forensic evidence. South African investigators had concluded that Annie had been killed by a bullet fired from between 5 and 10 centimetres away. This was contested on Panorama by Mark Mestaglio, a leading firearms expert at the UK's Forensic Science Service. He found that the size and pattern of the gunshot and residue indicated a firing position of less than 5 centimetres. Mestaglio suspected that the gun went off when pressed right up against Annie, perhaps during a struggle. Angela Shaw, one of the UK's leading experts on gunshot residue, told Panorama that the South African police had failed to test|||当时他正坐在副驾驶座上——这一说法后来被认为与法医证据不符。南非调查人员得出的结论是，安妮是被从5到10厘米的距离发射的子弹杀害的。英国法医科学署的顶尖枪械专家马克·梅斯特利亚吉在《广角镜》节目中对此提出了质疑。他发现枪击和残留物的尺寸及图案表明发射距离不到5厘米。梅斯特利亚吉怀疑枪是在紧贴着安妮的情况下走火的，也许是在搏斗过程中。英国首屈一指的枪击残留物专家安吉拉·肖在《广角镜》节目中表示，南非警方未能对
the hijacker's clothing and much of the taxi for gunshot residue. This meant she was unable to determine where the shooter had been positioned at the time Annie was shot. Several gaps in Zola Tongo's story were also pointed out, including his claim that Shreyan had said he wanted a client killed instead of simply naming Annie as his victim. Commentators from South Africa's criminal justice system expressed concern over how quickly Tongo's plea deal was arranged, with a former acting High Court judge stating, It seemed to me that the National Prosecution Service was under some political pressure to get some result as soon as possible. William Booth, chair of the country's
the hijacker's clothing and much of the taxi for gunshot residue. This meant she was unable to determine where the shooter had been positioned at the time Annie was shot. Several gaps in Zola Tongo's story were also pointed out, including his claim that Shreyan had said he wanted a client killed instead of simply naming Annie as his victim. Commentators from South Africa's criminal justice system expressed concern over how quickly Tongo's plea deal was arranged, with a former acting High Court judge stating, It seemed to me that the National Prosecution Service was under some political pressure to get some result as soon as possible. William Booth, chair of the country's|||劫匪的衣服以及出租车的许多部位进行枪击残留物检测。这意味着她无法确定安妮中枪时枪手所处的位置。佐拉·通戈的说法中也被指出了几个漏洞，包括他声称施雷扬说过他想杀一个客户，而不是直接点名安妮作为他的受害者。南非刑事司法系统的评论员对通戈的认罪协议达成得如此之快表示担忧，一位前高等法院代理法官表示：“在我看来，国家检察机关承受着某种政治压力，急于尽快取得某种结果。”该国
criminal law committee, said, In South Africa, things are not happening as they should. I don't believe the prosecution authorities are checking up on their evidence beforehand. It's like, we've got to nail somebody, so let's just go for it. Panorama also spoke to witnesses who had encountered Annie and Shreyan in South Africa. The waitress who served the couple on their first night in Cape Town stated that they showed little affection to one another, which was unusual compared to other honeymooners she had waited on. Symbol Nile Matakazi, the local man who had helped Shreyan call police after the hijacking, said that he believed Shreyan's distress after the crime had been genuine. Symbol Nile had been
criminal law committee, said, In South Africa, things are not happening as they should. I don't believe the prosecution authorities are checking up on their evidence beforehand. It's like, we've got to nail somebody, so let's just go for it. Panorama also spoke to witnesses who had encountered Annie and Shreyan in South Africa. The waitress who served the couple on their first night in Cape Town stated that they showed little affection to one another, which was unusual compared to other honeymooners she had waited on. Symbol Nile Matakazi, the local man who had helped Shreyan call police after the hijacking, said that he believed Shreyan's distress after the crime had been genuine. Symbol Nile had been|||刑法委员会主席威廉·布斯说：“在南非，事情没有按照应有的方式发展。我不相信检方在事前核对过他们的证据。这就像是，我们必须给某人定罪，所以就直接上吧。”《广角镜》还采访了在南非遇到过安妮和施雷扬的目击者。在开普敦的第一晚为这对夫妇服务的女服务员表示，他们之间表现出的爱意很少，与她接待过的其他度蜜月的人相比很不寻常。在劫车事件发生后帮助施雷扬报警的当地人辛博尔·尼尔·马塔卡齐表示，他相信施雷扬在案发后的痛苦是真诚的。辛博尔·尼尔在
surprised when he found out that Shreyan was accused of being involved with the murder plot. Annie's family were upset by the Panorama episode, viewing it as a trial by media before Shreyan had had his day in court. While Kolele Mungeni awaited trial in South Africa, he was diagnosed with a malignant brain tumor. Court proceedings were delayed as he underwent surgery and recommenced in August 2012. By then, Mungeni was significantly underweight and required the use of a walking frame. His lawyers claimed the confession he had made during his first police interview shouldn't be admissible in court, as it was made under duress, after Mungeni had been tortured by
surprised when he found out that Shreyan was accused of being involved with the murder plot. Annie's family were upset by the Panorama episode, viewing it as a trial by media before Shreyan had had his day in court. While Kolele Mungeni awaited trial in South Africa, he was diagnosed with a malignant brain tumor. Court proceedings were delayed as he underwent surgery and recommenced in August 2012. By then, Mungeni was significantly underweight and required the use of a walking frame. His lawyers claimed the confession he had made during his first police interview shouldn't be admissible in court, as it was made under duress, after Mungeni had been tortured by|||得知施雷扬被指控参与谋杀阴谋时感到很惊讶。安妮的家人对《广角镜》节目的播出感到不安，认为这是在施雷扬出庭受审前由媒体进行的审判。当科勒莱·姆恩盖尼在南非等待审判时，他被诊断出患有恶性脑瘤。随着他接受手术，法庭审判程序被推迟，并于2012年8月重新开始。到那时，姆恩盖尼明显体重过轻，需要使用助行架。他的律师声称他在第一次接受警方讯问时做出的供词不应在法庭上被采纳，因为那是他在遭受警方刑讯逼供后被迫做出的。
the police. The trial judge Robert Henney found no evidence of assault or coercion by the police, and ruled that the confession was admissible. Umsi Wamadoda Kwaabe and Monde Mblombo both testified at the trial that they and Mungeni had come to be involved in the hijacking via taxi driver Zola Tongo. Kwaabe said he and Mungeni had first met up with Tongo on the afternoon before the murder to discuss their plan for the hijacking. This was confirmed by two eyewitnesses who saw the three men sitting in a car together on the day in question. Kwaabe told the court that on the night of the hijacking, Mungeni had shot Annie after Tongo and Shreyan had been thrown out of the minivan. He and Mungeni then collected their payment from
the police. The trial judge Robert Henney found no evidence of assault or coercion by the police, and ruled that the confession was admissible. Umsi Wamadoda Kwaabe and Monde Mblombo both testified at the trial that they and Mungeni had come to be involved in the hijacking via taxi driver Zola Tongo. Kwaabe said he and Mungeni had first met up with Tongo on the afternoon before the murder to discuss their plan for the hijacking. This was confirmed by two eyewitnesses who saw the three men sitting in a car together on the day in question. Kwaabe told the court that on the night of the hijacking, Mungeni had shot Annie after Tongo and Shreyan had been thrown out of the minivan. He and Mungeni then collected their payment from|||主审法官罗伯特·亨尼没有发现警方存在殴打或胁迫的证据，并裁定该供词可以采纳。乌姆西·瓦马多达·夸贝和蒙德·姆布隆博都在审判中作证称，他们和姆恩盖尼是通过出租车司机佐拉·通戈卷入这起劫车案的。夸贝称，他和姆恩盖尼在谋杀发生前一天下午首次与通戈会面，商讨他们的劫车计划。两名目击证人证实了这一点，他们看到这三名男子在事发当天坐在一辆车里。夸贝告诉法庭，在劫车当晚，通戈和施雷扬被赶下面包车后，姆恩盖尼枪杀了安妮。随后他和姆恩盖尼从
the passenger seat, only to find it was 5,000 rand short of the amount they had requested. The two then retrieved the spent cartridge and threw it down a drain before abandoning the vehicle. A longtime friend of Mungeni's named Lukaya Basela testified that in the early hours after the murder, Mungeni had arrived at his house with Tongo's stolen mobile phone. Later that day, Mungeni confessed to Lukaya that he had robbed and shot a woman. Two days later, the police found Mungeni in Lukaya's home where Annie's Armani watch and white gold bracelet had been hidden in the roof. Mungeni claimed that the witnesses were lying and denied having any involvement in the crime, instead providing an alibi for the night
the passenger seat, only to find it was 5,000 rand short of the amount they had requested. The two then retrieved the spent cartridge and threw it down a drain before abandoning the vehicle. A longtime friend of Mungeni's named Lukaya Basela testified that in the early hours after the murder, Mungeni had arrived at his house with Tongo's stolen mobile phone. Later that day, Mungeni confessed to Lukaya that he had robbed and shot a woman. Two days later, the police found Mungeni in Lukaya's home where Annie's Armani watch and white gold bracelet had been hidden in the roof. Mungeni claimed that the witnesses were lying and denied having any involvement in the crime, instead providing an alibi for the night|||副驾驶座上拿走了报酬，却发现比他们要求的金额少了5,000兰特。两人随后找回了弹壳，将其扔进下水道，然后弃车逃跑。姆恩盖尼的一位老朋友卢卡亚·巴塞拉作证说，在谋杀发生后的凌晨，姆恩盖尼拿着通戈被偷的手机来到了他家。当天晚些时候，姆恩盖尼向卢卡亚坦白说自己抢劫并枪杀了一个女人。两天后，警察在卢卡亚的家中找到了姆恩盖尼，安妮的阿玛尼手表和白金手链就藏在屋顶里。姆恩盖尼声称证人在撒谎，并否认自己参与了这起犯罪，而是为案发当晚
of the murder. Judge Annie ultimately rejected the alibi, asserting that it didn't match the evidence presented by the prosecution. He found Mungeni guilty of all charges, except kidnapping, citing that kidnapping was part of the murder plot and would therefore be a duplication conviction. Mungeni was sentenced to life in prison. In England, Shreyan's defense team continued to argue that their client still wasn't well enough to be extradited to South Africa. In July 2013, Judge Howard Riddle again ruled that Shreyan be extradited. But Shreyan appealed the decision. Three months later, several judges questioned whether it might be unjust and oppressive to send Shreyan back to South Africa before his mental
of the murder. Judge Annie ultimately rejected the alibi, asserting that it didn't match the evidence presented by the prosecution. He found Mungeni guilty of all charges, except kidnapping, citing that kidnapping was part of the murder plot and would therefore be a duplication conviction. Mungeni was sentenced to life in prison. In England, Shreyan's defense team continued to argue that their client still wasn't well enough to be extradited to South Africa. In July 2013, Judge Howard Riddle again ruled that Shreyan be extradited. But Shreyan appealed the decision. Three months later, several judges questioned whether it might be unjust and oppressive to send Shreyan back to South Africa before his mental|||提供了不在场证明。安妮法官最终驳回了这一不在场证明，断言其与控方出示的证据不符。他裁定姆恩盖尼除绑架罪外其余所有指控均成立，理由是绑架是谋杀阴谋的一部分，因此属于重复定罪。姆恩盖尼被判处终身监禁。在英国，施雷扬的辩护团队继续辩称，他们的客户身体状况仍然不足以被引渡到南非。2013年7月，法官霍华德·里德尔再次裁定将施雷扬引渡。但施雷扬对该决定提出了上诉。三个月后，几位法官质疑在施雷扬的心理健康问题痊愈之前将其遣送回南非是否会显得不够公正且具有压迫性。
health issues had cleared. Yet another hearing took place on January 31, 2014. But on this occasion, the judges rejected Shreyan's appeal and upheld Judge Riddle's ruling. Annie's father, Vinod, had flown to England from Sweden to attend the hearing, while his wife Nalaam was forced to stay home as her health had suffered significantly following her daughter's murder. Vinod later wrote of his relief at the ruling in his book, Annie Diwani, a father's story. It had been a long three and a half year wait, a wretched time for us. There had been upset after upset, endless tears, and the suffering, torment and pain my wonderful family had endured amounted to nothing short of persecution. All we had ever asked for was the truth.
health issues had cleared. Yet another hearing took place on January 31, 2014. But on this occasion, the judges rejected Shreyan's appeal and upheld Judge Riddle's ruling. Annie's father, Vinod, had flown to England from Sweden to attend the hearing, while his wife Nalaam was forced to stay home as her health had suffered significantly following her daughter's murder. Vinod later wrote of his relief at the ruling in his book, Annie Diwani, a father's story. It had been a long three and a half year wait, a wretched time for us. There had been upset after upset, endless tears, and the suffering, torment and pain my wonderful family had endured amounted to nothing short of persecution. All we had ever asked for was the truth.|||2014年1月31日，又一次听证会举行了。但在这次听证会上，法官们驳回了施雷扬的上诉，维持了里德尔法官的裁决。安妮的父亲维诺德从瑞典飞往英国出席听证会，而他的妻子娜拉姆则被迫留在家中，因为女儿遇害后她的健康状况遭受了重大打击。维诺德后来在他的书《安妮·迪瓦尼：一位父亲的故事》中写下了他对这一裁决的释怀：“这是一场漫长而三年半的等待，对我们来说是一段悲惨的时光。一次又一次的打击，无尽的眼泪，我伟大的家庭所承受的苦难、折磨和痛苦简直就是迫害。我们一直要求的只是真相。”
The one person who could help us had remained 6,000 miles away from his accusers for all that time. Now, the wait was over. Authorities in South Africa were required to make special arrangements for Shreyan's return. He was to be flown to Cape Town on a private charter plane at the cost of almost 3 million South African rent, or the equivalent of approximately 247,000 Australian dollars. Rather than being held on remand, he would be staying at the Valkenburg Psychiatric Hospital, where a private room would be redecorated in anticipation of his arrival. On April 7, 2014, Shreyan Diwani arrived in Cape Town, where he was arrested and charged
The one person who could help us had remained 6,000 miles away from his accusers for all that time. Now, the wait was over. Authorities in South Africa were required to make special arrangements for Shreyan's return. He was to be flown to Cape Town on a private charter plane at the cost of almost 3 million South African rent, or the equivalent of approximately 247,000 Australian dollars. Rather than being held on remand, he would be staying at the Valkenburg Psychiatric Hospital, where a private room would be redecorated in anticipation of his arrival. On April 7, 2014, Shreyan Diwani arrived in Cape Town, where he was arrested and charged|||唯一能帮助我们的人在那段漫长的时间里一直远在6,000英里之外，远离他的指控者。现在，等待结束了。南非当局被要求为施雷扬的回归做出特殊安排。他将乘坐私人包机飞往开普敦，费用近300万南非兰特（相当于约247,000澳元）。他不会被关押在审前拘留所，而是将住在瓦尔肯堡精神病院，那里的一间私人房间将重新装修以迎接他的到来。2014年4月7日，施雷扬·迪瓦尼抵达开普敦，并在那里被逮捕并起诉，
with conspiracy to commit kidnapping, robbery with aggravating circumstances, kidnapping, murder, and obstructing the administration of justice. He pleaded not guilty to wall charges. Shreyan's trial commenced six months later, on October 6, 2014, with the judge Jeanette Traverso presiding. In a highly unusual move, proceedings began with Shreyan's defense counsel reading a statement prepared by their client, who wanted to explain to the court why he was pleading not guilty. In the statement, Shreyan spoke of his love for Ani and his commitment to their relationship, while also acknowledging that they'd had some disagreements prior to their wedding.
with conspiracy to commit kidnapping, robbery with aggravating circumstances, kidnapping, murder, and obstructing the administration of justice. He pleaded not guilty to wall charges. Shreyan's trial commenced six months later, on October 6, 2014, with the judge Jeanette Traverso presiding. In a highly unusual move, proceedings began with Shreyan's defense counsel reading a statement prepared by their client, who wanted to explain to the court why he was pleading not guilty. In the statement, Shreyan spoke of his love for Ani and his commitment to their relationship, while also acknowledging that they'd had some disagreements prior to their wedding.|||罪名包括串谋绑架、加重情节抢劫、绑架、谋杀以及妨碍司法公正。他对所有指控均做出了无罪抗辩。施雷扬的审判于六个月后的2014年10月6日开始，由法官珍妮特·特拉韦索主持。在一个极其罕见的举动中，诉讼程序以施雷扬的辩护律师宣读由其客户准备的一份声明开始，客户希望向法庭解释他为何做无罪抗辩。在声明中，施雷扬谈到了他对安妮的爱以及对这段关系的承诺，同时也承认他们在婚礼前确实有过一些分歧。
He outlined the events of their honeymoon up to and including the night they were hijacked, and detailed the ongoing trauma he'd experienced following Ani's death. As a consequence of the traumatic experience which resulted in the loss of my wife, I have been hospitalized for over three years and suffered from severe post-traumatic stress disorder. This and the resultant flashbacks, nightmares, and anxiety attacks have affected my memory and impacted on my ability to precisely and chronologically recall events concerning this terrible incident. Shreyan's statement also addressed his sexuality, which had been discussed in a number of tabloid articles in the years following the crime. He explained that he was
He outlined the events of their honeymoon up to and including the night they were hijacked, and detailed the ongoing trauma he'd experienced following Ani's death. As a consequence of the traumatic experience which resulted in the loss of my wife, I have been hospitalized for over three years and suffered from severe post-traumatic stress disorder. This and the resultant flashbacks, nightmares, and anxiety attacks have affected my memory and impacted on my ability to precisely and chronologically recall events concerning this terrible incident. Shreyan's statement also addressed his sexuality, which had been discussed in a number of tabloid articles in the years following the crime. He explained that he was|||他概述了他们的蜜月经历，直至并包括他们被劫持的那天晚上，并详细描述了他在安妮死后经历的持续创伤：“由于失去了妻子的创伤经历，我住院治疗了三年多，并患上了严重的创伤后应激障碍。这以及随之而来的闪回、噩梦和焦虑发作影响了我的记忆力，并削弱了我准确且按时间顺序回忆与这起可怕事件相关的事件的能力。”施雷扬的声明还谈到了他的性取向，这在犯罪发生后的几年里一直是许多小报文章讨论的话题。他解释说自己是
bisexual and had slept with both women and men, including German sex worker Leopold Leiser, who had previously spoken with the press about his encounters with Shreyan. As Shreyan had steadfastly denied these allegations for almost four years, this admission came as a shock to many, including the Hindocha family. The prosecution considered Shreyan's sexuality as the motive behind Ani's murder. They presented evidence that Shreyan had maintained a user profile at a dating website for gay and bisexual men called Gaydar since August 2004. Computer forensic analysts had found that Shreyan had logged on to the site twice on November 12, 2010, while he and Ani were at Johannesburg Airport,
bisexual and had slept with both women and men, including German sex worker Leopold Leiser, who had previously "spoken with the press about his encounters with Shreyan. As Shreyan had steadfastly denied these allegations for almost four years, this admission came as a shock to many, including the Hindocha family. The prosecution considered Shreyan's sexuality as the motive behind Ani's murder. They presented evidence that Shreyan had maintained a user profile at a dating website for gay and bisexual men called Gaydar since August 2004. Computer forensic analysts had found that Shreyan had logged on to the site twice on November 12, 2010, while he and Ani were at Johannesburg Airport,|||双性恋，曾与女性和男性发生过性关系，包括德国性工作者莱奥波德·莱瑟，后者此前曾向媒体讲述了他与施雷扬的交往经历。由于施雷扬近四年来一直坚决否认这些指控，这一供认让许多人感到震惊，包括欣多查家族。控方认为施雷扬的性取向是谋杀安妮的动机。他们出示了证据，证明施雷扬自2004年8月起就在一个名为Gaydar的同性恋和双性恋男性交友网站上维护着一个用户资料。计算机法证分析师发现，2010年11月12日，当他和安妮在约翰内斯堡机场等待飞往开普敦的航班时，施雷扬曾两次登录该网站。
waiting for their flight to Cape Town. He had also accessed the site for three years, for three hours on November 15, 2010, less than 48 hours after Ani's murder. An examination of Shreyan's laptop had also revealed 53 emails between himself and a man who wasn't named in court, some of which were sexually explicit. While this evidence was being presented, Judge Traverso suddenly intervened and stated that Shreyan's sexuality was irrelevant to the murder charge, as he had already addressed the matter in his opening statement. She banned the prosecution from presenting their next witness, German sex worker Leopold
waiting for their flight to Cape Town. He had also accessed the site for three years, for three hours on November 15, 2010, less than 48 hours after Ani's murder. An examination of Shreyan's laptop had also revealed 53 emails between himself and a man who wasn't named in court, some of which were sexually explicit. While this evidence was being presented, Judge Traverso suddenly intervened and stated that Shreyan's sexuality was irrelevant to the murder charge, as he had already addressed the matter in his opening statement. She banned the prosecution from presenting their next witness, German sex worker Leopold|||他还曾在2010年11月15日（安妮遇害后不到48小时）访问该网站长达三个小时。对施雷扬笔记本电脑的检查还显示了他与一名未在法庭上具名的男子之间的53封电子邮件，其中一些邮件包含露骨的色情内容。正当这些证据被出示时，特拉韦索法官突然介入，并声明施雷扬的性取向与谋杀指控无关，因为他已经在开场陈述中谈到了这个问题。她禁止控方传唤他们的下一位证人——德国性工作者莱奥波德·
Eliza, who had intended to testify about his sexual encounters with Shreyan. The prosecution then called Ani's cousin, Snaya, to the stand, although Judge Traverso had deemed most of her planned testimony to be inadmissible. Snaya discussed some of the text messages she had received from Ani in the months preceding her death, and spoke about Shreyan's strange behavior in the days following Ani's murder. In regards to Shreyan's initial claim that it had been Ani who requested the couple drive through the Cape Flats, Snaya stated that Ani would never ask such a thing. By this point, taxi driver Zola Tongo had already served almost four years for his
Eliza, who had intended to testify about his sexual encounters with Shreyan. The prosecution then called Ani's cousin, Snaya, to the stand, although Judge Traverso had deemed most of her planned testimony to be inadmissible. Snaya discussed some of the text messages she had received from Ani in the months preceding her death, and spoke about Shreyan's strange behavior in the days following Ani's murder. In regards to Shreyan's initial claim that it had been Ani who requested the couple drive through the Cape Flats, Snaya stated that Ani would never ask such a thing. By this point, taxi driver Zola Tongo had already served almost four years for his|||莱瑟，他原本打算作证讲述他与施雷扬的性接触。随后，控方传唤了安妮的表妹斯娜娅出庭作证，尽管特拉韦索法官认为她计划的大部分证词都不可采纳。斯娜娅谈到了她在安妮死前几个月收到的一些短信，并讲述了安妮遇害后几天里施雷扬的奇怪行为。关于施雷扬最初声称是安妮要求这对夫妇驾车穿过开普平地的说法，斯娜娅表示安妮绝不会提出这种要求。此时，出租车司机佐拉·通戈因为他在
role in orchestrating Ani's murder. In accordance with the plea deal he'd struck with prosecutors, Tongo testified that Shreyan had approached him about organizing a murder immediately after the couple arrived at the Cape Grace Hotel on Friday, November 12, 2010. Tongo explained that his friend Monde Mblombo had put him in touch with Umziwama Dota Kwaabe, who Tongo had then planned the murder with. He also told the court how he had helped Shreyan exchange his money to pay for the hit. Tongo testified that on Saturday, November 13, he was scheduled to pick up Shreyan and Ani at 7.30 p.m., but was delayed by about half an hour. An agitated sounding Shreyan had called to ask where he was, insisting the hit had to take place that night. The original plan was for
role in orchestrating Ani's murder. In accordance with the plea deal he'd struck with prosecutors, Tongo testified that Shreyan had approached him about organizing a murder immediately after the couple arrived at the Cape Grace Hotel on Friday, November 12, 2010. Tongo explained that his friend Monde Mblombo had put him in touch with Umziwama Dota Kwaabe, who Tongo had then planned the murder with. He also told the court how he had helped Shreyan exchange his money to pay for the hit. Tongo testified that on Saturday, November 13, he was scheduled to pick up Shreyan and Ani at 7.30 p.m., but was delayed by about half an hour. An agitated sounding Shreyan had called to ask where he was, insisting the hit had to take place that night. The original plan was for|||策划谋杀安妮中所扮演的角色，已经服刑近四年。根据他与检察官达成的认罪协议，通戈作证说，2010年11月12日星期五，这对夫妇刚到达开普格雷斯酒店后不久，施雷扬就找到他，商量策划一起谋杀。通戈解释说，他的朋友蒙德·姆布隆博把他介绍给了乌姆济瓦马·多塔·夸贝，随后通戈与夸贝一起策划了这场谋杀。他还告诉法庭他是如何帮施雷扬换钱来支付买凶杀人费用的。通戈作证说，11月13日星期六，他原定于晚上7点30分去接施雷扬和安妮，但耽误了大约半小时。一个听起来很焦躁的施雷扬打电话问他在哪里，坚持说今晚必须动手。最初的计划是
Kwaabe and Mungeni to carjack the vehicle earlier in the evening, but the two men were delayed due to a transportation issue. When Tongo dropped Shreyan and Ani at the Surfside Restaurant for dinner, Ani had walked inside, while Shreyan had pulled Tongo aside, demanding to know why the hit hadn't yet taken place. He threatened to kill Tongo if the plan didn't proceed, before following Ani into the restaurant. Shreyan then called Tongo during the meal, and Tongo reassured him that the murder would take place after dinner. When Shreyan and Ani were back in Tongo's minivan, phone records showed that Tongo had sent Shreyan a text message at 10.40 p.m., in which he claimed to have asked Shreyan where he had hidden the 15,000 rand for the hijackers.
夸贝和芒盖尼本计划在当晚早些时候劫车，但两人因交通问题耽误了。当汤戈将什里安和安妮送到冲浪者餐厅吃晚饭时，安妮先进了餐厅，而什里安把汤戈拉到一边，质问他为什么刺杀行动还没进行。他威胁汤戈说，如果计划不执行就杀了他，随后便跟着安妮进了餐厅。什里安在用餐期间给汤戈打了电话，汤戈向他保证谋杀将在晚饭后进行。当什里安和安妮回到汤戈的面包车上时，通话记录显示，汤戈在晚上10点40分给什里安发了一条短信，他在短信中声称自己问过什里安把给劫匪的1万5千兰特藏在哪里了。
According to Tongo, Shreyan had texted back to say the money was in an envelope in a pouch behind the passenger seat. At approximately 11 p.m., Tongo texted Kwaabe to let him know they were about to arrive in Gugoletu. The hijacking had taken place shortly after, and Tongo had then walked to a police station to report the incident. He told the court that it was only when the police were driving him back to the Cape Grace Hotel that he overheard them mention that Ani was Shreyan's wife. Tongo claimed he didn't know that the pair were married, as Shreyan had told him the murder victim was a client of his. At the Cape Grace Hotel, Tongo claimed that he and Shreyan spoke intermittently over the course of the night, with Shreyan approaching to ask whether the job had been
据汤戈供述，什里安回短信说钱在乘客座椅后面口袋的一个信封里。晚上11点左右，汤戈给夸贝发短信，告诉他们即将到达古戈莱图。劫案不久后便发生了，随后汤戈步行去警察局报案。他告诉法庭，直到警察开车送他回开普格雷斯酒店时，他才无意中听到他们提到安妮是什里安的妻子。汤戈声称自己不知道两人是夫妻，因为什里安告诉他谋杀受害者是自己的一位客户。在开普格雷斯酒店，汤戈声称他和什里安当晚断断续续地交谈过，什里安曾走过来询问行动是否已经
done. On Tuesday, November 15, Shreyan had asked him to come to the hotel to collect his 5000 rand finders fee. They met near a corridor in the lobby, and Shreyan gave Tongo an envelope in a plastic bag. Tongo went into a bathroom to check the envelope, only to find it contained 1000 rand instead of the 5000 they agreed to. He claimed he tried to find Shreyan, but never saw or spoke to him again. During cross-examination, the defense examined a number of holes in Tongo's story. Despite his claim that he had no further contact with Shreyan after the financial transaction, phone records indicated that Shreyan had made a 54-second phone call to Tongo one hour and 40 minutes after this incident. CCTV footage also appeared to refute Tongo's
完成了。11月15日星期二，什里安要求他去酒店领取5000兰特的寻人报酬。他们在大堂的走廊附近碰面，什里安给了汤戈一个装在塑料袋里的信封。汤戈走进洗手间检查信封，却发现里面只有1000兰特，而不是他们商定的5000兰特。他声称自己试图寻找什里安，但再也没有见到或与他说过话。在盘问过程中，辩方指出了汤戈说辞中的诸多漏洞。尽管他声称在完成这笔财务交易后与什里安再无联系，但通话记录表明，在这次事件发生一小时四十分钟后，什里安曾给汤戈打过一个54秒的电话。监控录像似乎也反驳了汤戈的
assertion that Shreyan had called him in an agitated state around 7.30pm on the night of the murder. Security cameras in the lobby of the Cape Grace Hotel had captured Shreyan making this call, but he appeared calm and was standing right next to Annie the whole time. CCTV footage also disproved Tongo's claim that Shreyan had accosted him outside the Surfside Restaurant after Annie went inside alone. Security cameras had captured Shreyan walking ahead of Annie, who was trailing behind, and a waiter had confirmed to BBC Panorama that Shreyan had entered the restaurant first. The defense insisted that Shreyan had only ever contacted Tongo to book taxi appointments, as he and Annie had liked his friendly personality and were happy
说法，即什里安在谋杀当晚7点30分左右曾情绪激动地给他打电话。开普格雷斯酒店大堂的安防摄像头拍到了什里安打这通电话的画面，但他看起来很平静，而且全程都站在安妮身边。监控录像还推翻了汤戈的说法，即什里安在安妮独自进入餐厅后曾在冲浪者餐厅外拦住他。安防摄像头拍到什里安走在安妮前面，安妮则落在后面，一名服务员向英国广播公司《全景》栏目证实，什里安是先进入餐厅的。辩方坚称，什里安联系汤戈只是为了预约出租车，因为他和安妮很喜欢汤戈友善的性格，并乐意
to have him show for them around Cape Town. In regards to the US dollars that Tongo had helped Shreyan exchange, the defense said that Shreyan planned to use the money to book a scenic helicopter trip to surprise Annie, which cost around $10,000. Tongo was helping him arrange the helicopter ride, which explained why Shreyan had met with Tongo the night before the murder, as well as the various text messages sent between the two. Monday in Blombo, the man who had introduced Tongo to the hijackers, was also called to testify on behalf of the prosecution. Blombo stated that Tongo had told him that a husband wanted his wife killed, which contradicted Tongo's claim that he didn't know Annie and Shreyan were married.
让汤戈带着他们在开普敦四处游览。关于汤戈帮什里安兑换的美元，辩方称什里安计划用这笔钱预订一次观光直升机之旅给安妮一个惊喜，费用约为1万美元。汤戈一直在帮他安排直升机之旅，这就解释了为什么什里安在谋杀前一晚会与汤戈会面，以及两人之间发送的各种短信。布伦博在布隆博，这个将汤戈介绍给劫匪的人，也被传唤为控方作证。布隆博表示，汤戈曾对他说过，有一个丈夫想杀自己的妻子，这与汤戈声称自己不知道安妮和什里安是夫妻的说法相矛盾。
Blombo had been offered immunity in exchange for his testimony, as investigators thought his role in the plot was minimal. However, while he was on the stand, it was revealed that his involvement went further than police had initially believed. On the night of the murder, CCTV footage from the Protea Coliseum Hotel where in Blombo worked recorded him talking on the phone to Tongo and making several statements that sounded as though he was in charge, such as, this is how it's going to happen. During cross-examination, Blombo's evidence unraveled and he started to contradict himself on every aspect of his earlier police statements and the testimony he gave at Kolele Mungeni's trial.
布伦博因作证而获得了豁免权，因为调查人员认为他在阴谋中的作用微乎其微。然而，当他出庭作证时，人们发现他的卷入程度比警方最初认为的要深。谋杀当晚，布伦博工作的普罗蒂亚竞技场酒店的监控录像记录了他与汤戈通电话，并说了一些听起来像是他在发号施令的话，例如“事情就这么办”。在盘问过程中，布伦博的证词不攻自破，他开始在自己先前的警方供词以及在科莱勒·芒盖尼审判中的证词的每一个方面自相矛盾。
In the end, Judge Traverso rejected Blombo's immunity and declared him to be a self-confessed liar. Regardless, South Africa's National Prosecution Service never brought any charges against him. Umsiwama Dota Kwaabe's testimony resulted in further inconsistencies. Kwaabe claimed that 10,000 rand had been stashed behind the passenger seat as payment for the hit, which he and Mungeni had split. However, Mungeni claimed they only received 4,000 rand, which they had stolen from Shrian at gunpoint. In further contrast, Shrian claimed that the hijackers had robbed him of between 5,000 and 6,000 rand. Of all these claims, the evidence supported Mungeni's version of events, as he was found to have spent just under
最终，法官特拉维索驳回了对布伦博的豁免权，并宣布他是一个自认的撒谎者。尽管如此，南非国家公诉机关从未对他提出任何指控。乌姆西瓦马·多塔·夸贝的证词导致了更多的矛盾。夸贝声称，座椅背后藏有1万兰特作为谋杀的报酬，他和芒盖尼平分了这笔钱。然而，芒盖尼声称他们只得到了4000兰特，这是他们持枪从什里安那里抢来的。相比之下，什里安声称劫匪抢走了他5000到6000兰特。在所有这些说法中，证据支持芒盖尼的说法，因为人们发现他在谋杀案发生后的第二天花了不到
2,000 rand on shoes and clothes the day after the murder. The prosecution's case was also hindered by issues with the forensic evidence. Kwaabe asserted that Mungeni had shot Annie from the front passenger seat, which the prosecution conceded wasn't forensically possible. A police ballistics expert who had reconstructed the layout of Tongo's minivan had made significant errors by using a different vehicle entirely, which resulted in the defense deriding him during cross-examination. The exact details surrounding Annie's murder remained a mystery. On November 17, 2014, the prosecution rested their case, and Shrian's defense team immediately applied to have the trial dismissed under Section 174 of South Africa's Criminal
2000兰特购买鞋子和衣服。控方的案件也因法医证据方面的问题而受阻。夸贝坚称芒盖尼是从前排乘客座位上枪击安妮的，控方承认从法医角度来看这是不可能的。一名曾重建汤戈面包车布局的警方弹道学专家犯了重大错误，他完全使用了另一辆车，导致他在盘问中遭到辩方的嘲笑。围绕安妮谋杀案的确切细节仍然是个谜。2014年11月17日，控方完成举证，什里安的辩护团队立即根据南非《刑事
Procedure Act. This statute allows the court to return a verdict of not guilty at the end of the prosecution's case if it's deemed there's no evidence that the accused committed a crime. Judge Traverso considered the submission, and on December 8, she ordered that the case against Shrian Diwani be dismissed, having found that there was insufficient evidence upon which a reasonable court could convict him. In explaining her conclusion, Judge Traverso noted that Tongo was the only witness who could directly connect Shrian to the crime, but his testimony contained too many inaccuracies and lies to be deemed credible. She noted that Tongo, Mblombo, and Quabe were all intelligent individuals capable of twisting
诉讼法》第174条申请驳回审判。如果法庭认为没有证据表明被告犯罪，该法规允许法庭在控方举证结束后作出无罪判决。特拉维索法官审议了这一呈请，并于12月8日下令驳回针对什里安·迪瓦尼的案件，她认为没有足够的证据可以让一个理性的法庭将其定罪。在解释她的结论时，特拉维索法官指出，汤戈是唯一能够将什里安与罪行直接联系起来的证人，但他的证词包含太多不准确之处和谎言，不足以被视为可信。她指出，汤戈、姆隆博和夸贝都是精明的人，有能力扭曲
their testimonies to implicate Shrian. Judge Traverso added that a person couldn't be prosecuted without credible evidence, simply in the hope that he might incriminate himself while on the stand. In conclusion, she stated, Regrettably, there are many unanswered questions about what exactly happened on the fateful night. I realized that there is a strong public opinion that the accused should be placed on his defense. I have taken note of that. I have also taken note of the plight of the Hindoches. I have, however, taken an oath of office to uphold the rule of law and to administer justice without fear, favor, or prejudice. That I cannot do if I permit public opinion to influence
他们的证词来牵连什里安。特拉维索法官补充说，不能在没有可靠证据的情况下起诉一个人，仅仅是希望他在出庭时自证其罪。最后，她表示：“遗憾的是，关于那个命运之夜究竟发生了什么，还有许多未解之谜。我意识到，公众普遍认为应该让被告进行辩护。我已经注意到了这一点。我也注意到了欣多查一家的困境。然而，我宣誓就职以维护法治，并在没有恐惧、偏袒或偏见的情况下伸张正义。如果我允许公众舆论影响
my application of the law. In the light of the analysis of the state case, there is no evidence upon which a reasonable court, acting carefully, can convict the accused. With the trial dismissed, Shrian Diwani was free to go. Annie's family were devastated by the decision. In Vinod Hindoches' book, he wrote, If I had not been sitting down, my legs would have buckled and I would have fallen to the floor. I looked at my family and saw their pain. Everybody was beginning to move around me, but everything was silent in my head. I saw Diwani walk towards the exit of the dock and disappear down the stairs, refusing to look at us as he passed. They let him slip out of the
我对法律的应用，我就无法做到这一点。根据对国家案件的分析，没有证据可以让一个小心谨慎的理性法庭对被告定罪。”随着审判被驳回，什里安·迪瓦尼重获自由。安妮的家人对这一决定感到痛不欲生。维诺德·欣多查在书中写道：“如果我当时不是坐着的，我的双腿就会发软，然后摔倒在地上。我看着家人，看到了他们的痛苦。周围所有的人都在走动，但我的脑子里一片寂静。我看到迪瓦尼走向被告席的出口，消失在楼梯深处，路过时拒绝看我们一眼。他们让他从
Western Cape Court without telling us what happened. Outside court, Annie's sister, Ami, told the press, Today we feel as a family that the justice system has failed us and we are deeply disappointed. We came here looking for answers and we came here looking for the truth, and all we got was more questions. We waited patiently for four years to hear what really happened to Annie. The hope of actually finding that out has kept us as a family going. Unfortunately, we believed that this riot has now been taken away from us because we never heard the full story of Shrian. We heard that Shrian has led a double life and that Annie knew nothing about it, and we just wish that Shrian had been honest with us and especially with Annie.
西开普省高级法院溜走，却没有告诉我们发生了什么。”法院外，安妮的姐姐阿米对媒体表示：“今天，我们作为一家人感到司法系统让我们失望了，我们深感失望。我们来到这里是为了寻找答案，我们来到这里是为了寻找真相，而我们得到的却只有更多的问题。我们耐心地等待了四年，想要知道安妮到底发生了什么。真正找出真相的希望支撑着我们一家人走到今天。不幸的是，我们认为这种慰藉现在已经被剥夺了，因为我们从未听到什里安的完整故事。我们听说什里安过着双重生活，而安妮对此一无所知，我们只希望什里安对我们坦诚相待，尤其是对安妮坦诚相待。”
Not ever knowing what happened to my dearest little sister on the 13th of November 2010, that's going to haunt me, my family, my brother, my parents, for the rest of our lives. Prior to Shrian's trial, the Hindoches had requested that an inquest into Annie's death be opened in the UK. In February 2015, the inquest commenced in London's Coroner's Court, but Senior Coroner Andrew Walker determined that the matter wouldn't proceed any further. He stated, The fact that there are differing accounts of how Mrs. Diwani came by her death does not, in my view, mean that the matters have not already been sufficiently established
“永远不知道在2010年11月13日那天我最亲爱的小妹妹身上到底发生了什么，这件事将一直萦绕在我、我的家人、我的兄弟、我的父母心头，直到我们生命的尽头。”在什里安受审之前，欣多查一家曾要求在英国对安妮的死因进行死因研讯。2015年2月，死因研讯在伦敦验尸官法院开始审理，但高级验尸官安德鲁·沃克决定不再进一步审理此案。他表示：“关于迪瓦尼夫人是如何丧生的存在不同说法，在我看来，这并不意味着这些事情尚未在公开诉讼中得到充分查明
in public proceedings. Coroner Walker said he was prohibited from reaching a conclusion that contradicted the findings of the South African courts, but indicated that the inquest could be reopened in the future if new evidence came to light. Shrian Diwani returned to the UK where he maintained a low profile. His family refused to speak to the media, other than to say they were glad that Shrian's name had been cleared. In Shrian's hometown of Bristol, public opinion was divided as to whether or not he was innocent. Some members of the community verbally abused the journalists who gathered outside the Diwani family home in the days following the trial, while others shouted the word killer in the
。”沃克验尸官表示，他被禁止作出与南非法院裁决相矛盾的结论，但表示如果出现新的证据，未来可以重新开启死因研讯。什里安·迪瓦尼返回英国后保持低调。他的家人拒绝接受媒体采访，只是表示很高兴什里安的清白得以恢复。在什里安的家乡布里斯托尔，公众对他是无辜的还是有罪的看法不一。在审判后的几天里，一些社区成员对聚集在迪瓦尼家族住宅外的记者进行言语辱骂，而另一些人则在房子
direction of the house. The driveway of their property was paint-bombed, and a monopoly-inspired get-out-of-jail free card was left by the gates. Kolele Mungeni died in the hospital ward of Goodwood Prison as a result of his brain tumor, after serving just two years of his life sentence. In September 2016, intended prosecution witness Leopold Leiser, the sex worker who had previously engaged in sexual activity with Shrian Diwani, died by suicide. A police investigation revealed that Leopold had been suffering from stress as a result of the trial. In 2018, it was reported that Shrian was in a relationship with a man and the pair were
方向大喊“杀人犯”。他们住所的车道被喷上了油漆弹，大门旁还被留了一张受《大富翁》启发而制作的“免狱卡”。科莱勒·芒盖尼在服刑两年后，因脑瘤在古德伍德监狱的病房里去世。2016年9月，原本的控方证人利奥帕德·莱瑟——曾与什里安·迪瓦尼发生过性行为的性工作者——自杀身亡。一项警方调查显示，利奥帕德一直因这场审判而承受着压力。2018年，据报道什里安与一名男子确立了恋爱关系，两人
living together in West London. On September 6, 2019, Zola Tongo became eligible for parole after serving half of his 18-year sentence. He submitted his parole application in May 2019, with the board expected to make a decision the following month. As South Africa employs a restorative justice program to help inform parole hearings, and his father Vinod returned to the country to speak with Tongo. Details of their meeting haven't been publicly revealed, but South African newspaper IOL quoted Vinod as stating, We didn't get what we wanted. He's still not telling the truth. As of the release of this episode, there has been no news regarding Tongo's possible parole.
一同住在西伦敦。2019年9月6日，佐拉·汤戈在服刑18年的一半后获得了假释资格。他在2019年5月提交了假释申请，预计委员会将在次月做出决定。由于南非采用恢复性司法计划来协助评估假释听证会，其父亲维诺德返回该国与汤戈交谈。他们会面的细节尚未公开透露，但南非报纸《IOL》援引维诺德的话说：“我们没有得到我们想要的。他仍然没有说实话。”截至本集发布时，尚未有关于汤戈可能获得假释的新消息。
Mondeim Blombo has never been charged in relation to Annie's murder, and Umsi-Wamadoda-Kwabe remains behind bars. To express the Hindocha family's struggle with grief and the criminal justice system in the years that followed Annie's murder, Vinod Hindocha wrote a book titled, Annie Diwani, A Father's Story. Towards the book's conclusion, Vinod expressed his relief that Annie's marriage was never legally formalized, writing, You remained a Hindocha, one of us, not one of his. The month after the book was published, Vinod was fixing an elevator near his hometown of Maristod when the chain slipped, sending him hurtling to the ground. The force of the drop caused his right arm to be ripped off just below the shoulder.
蒙代姆·布伦博从未因谋杀安妮一案而被起诉，乌姆西-瓦马多达-夸贝仍然身陷囹圄。为了表达欣多查一家在安妮被谋杀后的几年里与悲伤和刑事司法系统的抗争，维诺德·欣多查写了一本名为《安妮·迪瓦尼：一个父亲的故事》的书。在书的结尾，维诺德表达了他的欣慰，即安妮的婚姻从未在法律上正式确立，他写道：“你依然是欣多查，是我们的一员，而不是他的人。”这本书出版的第二个月，维诺德正在他家乡马里斯特德附近修理电梯，当时链条滑落，把他狠狠地摔在地上。坠落的力量导致他的右臂在肩膀下方被当场扯断。
Vinod was airlifted to hospital, where doctors managed to reattach his arm after 16 hours of surgery. Following the operation, he underwent physiotherapy to aid in his recovery. Vinod spoke to the Daily Mail about the experience, stating, After the operation, I had a lot of pain everywhere, but I could feel somebody dressing the pain. Maybe it is my imagination, but it was Annie. I believe she was there taking care of me. I still believe she is here. She is here, until she gets justice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
维诺德被空运到医院，医生经过16小时的手术成功为他重新接上手臂。手术后，他接受了物理治疗以帮助恢复。维诺德向《每日邮报》讲述了这段经历，并表示：“手术后，我到处都很痛，但我能感觉到有人在为伤口敷药。也许这是我的想象，但那是安妮。我相信她在那里照顾我。我依然相信她就在这里。她就在这里，直到正义得以伸张。”本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。